ajoutez donc on doit attendre ouais ça y
est je suis là on va se faire plaisir
aujourd'hui mon seb je n'ai pas mis sur
un match de merde huitièmes de finale
c'est ça ah ouais là je t'ai mis sur le
jeu tu es chez toi je t'ai mis sur le
match le match à suivre quoi alors à
quand on va rajouter les calmes les gars
je vais me rajouter en premier grâce
vous savez après est ce que c'est la
première fois non c'est un rapide c'est
la première fois qu'on commente des
beats ensemble je crois
ah ouais c'est la première fois depuis
je n'ai rien commenté donc je vais
peut-être commenté une fois quelque
chose avec toi tu en avais pas fait une
ronde de candidats il ya longtemps
moi c'est possible mais pas sûr bon en
tout cas en tout cas ça me fait plaise
c'est de te retrouver ici ouais bah moi
aussi et j'espère et j'espère que maxime
va bien il inauguré sa il était dans le
chat avant il est déjà chaud et choqué
il est très chaud il est pas là pour il
est pas là pour rigoler à notre ami
maxime donc alors c'est quoi c'est dû 5
+13 plus un plus un ça oui et ça dure
quatre heures alors juste on a une
insight jo qu'en fait c'est que les
matches sont très long way et il se
trouve que j'ai participé à des meetings
chaise comme en disant l'argument les
gars c'est quand même un peu long ce
serait bien de raccourcir pour le public
parce que parfois il ya des gars qui se
prennent juste un très souvent en fait
tu verras que c'est des massacres et sur
quoi on m'a répondu texto que c'était
bien les matchs où l'on passe comment on
était sûr que le meilleur gagne et est
donc en fait c'est de là que vient la
délire si tu nous entends dire de temps
en temps est on vraiment bien sûr que le
meilleur a gagné
ne faudrait-il pas joué 12 ou 14 heures
de plus et est-ce suffisant finalement
donc voilà scully dans le chat les gens
qui écrivent sommes nous bien sûr ou
quoi ça c'est un rapport avec ça ok
c'est noté
allez c'est parti pour quatre ans au
bonheur oui mais ça c'est du coup la sas
et oui c'est la question se pose si
maxime gagne les gars on dit tout à
l'heure qu'on sera bien sûr c'est si on
y signale sarine gagne c'est qu'il ya eu
un problème de bamiyan zain qui gagnent
pas possible normalement non alors
attends attends je suis en train je suis
en train de bien de bien tout cadré
désolé si tu me mentent en partir ça
commence à 18h c'est ça normalement oui
ok normalement il doit pas y avoir de
bluff mais tu vas voir en réalité c'est
si le match est serré c'est vraiment
très très cool à suivre du coup je suis
sur quoi moi je reste sur mon écran je
reste sur wii je serai sûr j'étais
inquiet brightwell sur skype ouais ouais
ouais sur skype
quand ça quand ça va partir on aura on
aura tout juste en train de m'embêter à
mettre tout les cas mais en fait c'était
soit on arrivait en live et on avait
tout bien cadré direct soit je faisais
le live avant et on avait ce petit
problème j'ai décidé que c'était plus
marrant de wen a eu raison
c'est tout à fait raison le petit live
avant façon je le fais à la bien un
tueur ans mais tranquille il est déguisé
en quoi maso mazout et déguisés en masse
aujourd'hui n'en était déguisé en vache
tranquille défaire comme un dimanche
sarah les petits vont bien depuis mardi
soir mardi on a touché les sommets
elle est grandiose
ils ont fait plaisir ouais non plus
c'était sympa quoi ouais ils sont malins
ils sont mignons ils reprennent l'école
de 20 l'école reprend demain
ça fait plaisir ça donc après deux
belles semaines de vacance de pouvoir un
petit peu un petit peu levé le pied
savourer mais les journées a donc mardi
on constate en une victoire
mardi c'est la victoire mais tu as tu
l'as pas précisé ah oui nanard vise 7 à
8 c sur
voilà mon avis c'est même pas la peine
de faire le tournoi oulala m val il a
mis son bon nul faut jure voir texto il
a mis son pull aux l'artiste
ah il est beau gosse ce soir mais il
n'ya le sarine dangereux ou pas là non
moi j'y crois pas je pense qu'en trois
ans 5 et 3 et valeurs il ya vraiment le
l'assassiner quoi le danger c'est
voulait troquer un bullet ils vont c'est
possible est ce qu'on connaît les
réseaux sociaux de maxime seat quoi
c'est hatem vl chess vachier lagrave est
nouvelle sur twitter twitter ses vaches
et la gorge ou non ces nouvelles sont
rudes
maintenant je vais checker
wells au le bon pull obliger ces vachier
lagrave ray rice qu'elle veille à un
autre on ignore pas tard ouais il a vu
son téléphone ou pas il ya dix mètres
sans téléphone de côté ouais j'imagine
que il y en a qu'un qui a le droit
d'utiliser le téléphone pour qu'on leur
dise c'est le carreau il a vraiment fait
une fois s'en sort à bon prix sont ces
personnes qui a rien dit j'y peux rien
c'est vrai et seignal ça rime et leur
jeu demain c'est demain vad c'est nous
qui le faisons la pré-soirée avec avec
mvele beaucoup de normes commenté qui on
command car le scène par i'm ok
prochaine c'est ça et après c'est toi
qui enchaîne qu'est-ce que j'enchaîne
déjà fait quoi je re tout 28 50 arrête
et en surtemps on doit alors j'ai un peu
joué là vraiment j'ai bien bien
stabilisé les 27 50 28 ans avant très
facilement
du coup là maintenant bon je pense que
avec un petit entraînement je peux
monter plus haut à la haye et puis en
plus si tu es 26t dans leur haine jeu 28
10 28 20 avant le title s'arrête bien
voilà je le serai sûr alors attends on
est bien ça passe ça a commencé ou pas à
temps je les vois la sape a commencé ça
s'étire le ca va pas commencer ça n'a
pas du tout comment ces écoutes on est
bon de toute façon j'aime y suivre donc
quand sa part sa part je pourrais je
pense comme comme tu le disais un ça va
être important pour maxime de faire un
gros début de match
ouais gros début de match 5 puissant je
pense vraiment qu'il va essayer de ckoi
c'est une heure et demie c'est quoi une
heure et demie une heure et demie une
heure c'est 1h30 1h30
pourquoi quatre heures du coup parce
qu'il ya des pauses parce que oui parce
qu'aussi hausse en fait si une partie
elles débutent à une minutes du gong en
fait on la joue jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
début toujours un petit peu en retard et
tout ça donc c'est bon pour ta d'après
le chat français évidemment ils vont
dire que c'est pas assez
eux c'est un scandale je jouais rue si
peu de temps c'est n'importe quoi c'est
une compétition qui ne reflète pas
vraiment le niveau il peut y avoir
beaucoup de surprises ça en étant je
peux pas grandir l'écran sky parce que
je vois l'échiquier en tout petit par
rapport à un regard tu vas le voir comme
ça après arriver là ok c'est juste moi
qui avant le début du match je garde là
pas de souci je garde la petite régis
toi d'être sûr après on va le voir en
grand et le chat tu le vois assez grand
arrive à lire le chat très bien tu vas
tu as ils te disent déjà que quatre
heures c'est très limite alors moins que
ça ce serait race contacter s'ils sont
très chaud dans le tchat
c'est un grave de faire des formats
aussi courte on va avoir du boulot
ah bah oui ça va monter à 2000 ce soir
j'espère c'est quoi le record de la
chaîne le record de la chaîne c'est 6000
ou pour alors c'était un gros événement
je sais plus lequel mais combine à une
première page switch on était genre déjà
3000 3300 en organique
genre comme ça et on a eu la première
page fuite sans au dessus ça on était
peut-être le deuxième ce crime le plus
regardé en france ou quelque chose comme
ça ok sarine sa reine il est jeune mais
je crois qu'il a 32 ou 33
le seul coup sûr en trois ans et la
sarine
ouais tu trolles ou oui tu parles tu
seras à oui tu trolles avec ton goût
kech oui
info que tu raconte cette histoire avec
vous cache là c'était quoi vous qu'est
ce
c'est arrive à un moment donné c'était
tournant à gibraltar ces femmes qui me
la raconter et tu dis c'est pas faux si
cela donne une mauvaise date de
naissance ce verdict
tu commences à le dire à tout le monde
et que les gens après parler de ça un
peu trop hâtif rata les attend ils
avaient une moustache de daron déjà
c'était impossible
il s'habille et déjà comme un corps un
homme de 40 ans et puis il avait une
tête de mecs de 40 ans et il avait 12
ans ou un truc comme ça avec rayons 11
ans et demi sur sa carte d'identité non
mais bon oui oui et tu as était parti un
truc comme ça et tout et tuent tout
femme edith avait fait un peu comme pour
botez missa olympiades
ouais c'est ça non mais s'arrête aussi
s'arrête j'ai joué quand il avait 11 ans
étaient les stars des sons l'impression
qu'ils avaient 35 en quoi c'était fou
quoi et écrivent 11 ans et demi hors pac
dans le tchat
ouais c'est ça mais il a l'air sympa
sarine en revanche way est sympa il aime
bien analyser les cool franchement elle
est cool il a l'air très sympa quand on
le voit jouer les matchs à la came to il
a toujours un peu souriant il une tête
d'un gars ces deux gars sympa
maxime il a la tête d'un gars là toi tu
vas pas les cas malheureusement avec le
partage mais j'ai pas si tu le vois
pardon mais un maxi 1000 à la tête et
peut-être de 4 à qui ce fichier est en
train de penser au match les lions à 21
heures et peut-être il se demande aussi
ce sera ton bien sûr la fin de son
message même valise à la tête d'un prof
qui a 55 copies à corriger
on nous dit nyan n'a aucune chance
ok c'est ma maxime gros favoris mais
c'est parce pas gagné d'avancé quand
même gros favoris gros gros favoris oui
et ce qui gagnera pas sûr il est
arrogant non plus sur wii play for sap
le jouer c'est quoi ces deux heures et
demie le décalage
il vit à new delhi alors attends je
crois que sa part je laisse regarder je
crois que ça comme était 2h30 et 22h30
le web est peut-être un couche-tard
en tout cas ces parties de cartes sont
partis espagnols alors aux îlots ils ont
un vrai donc ça arrive a quand même plus
de lots que maxime un sur trois comme
mais bon oui mais bon ça ça vaut rien
non parce que je pense que ça rit nuit
là en mode try hard et il donne tout
alors que maxime est en mode maximiser
le plaisir il peut largement monté à
3153 builders wells je pense aussi au
crédit ce soir la route 3150 tout est
possible alors oui c'est petit espagnol
t spécialistes ou pas webb à maxime
jousse as ligne qui joue en partie dans
la fameuse des 3 à 3 l'espagnol à 3 une
ligne ultra théorique qui joue depuis à
peu près deux ou trois ans et donc il
joue vraiment ces ouvertures deux
parties langue débats théoriques
ici vu qu'il n'ya plus vraiment de deux
parties longues
c'est vrai que c'est speech s ils
prennent une importance plus plus grand
de quoi forcément un ouais c'est ça
après bon il peut y avoir des nouveautés
incroyable parfois 25e qui peut mettre
de côté mes mais sinon il joue vraiment
ce qu'ils jouent normalement on n'a pas
prévu de changer avec les noirs
peut-être on peut s'attendre à des
surprises avec les blancs et joue ses
systèmes avec les noirs c'est vrai qu'il
est vite dans ces troncs internet c'est
les grünfeld et nash dorff il faudra
trop en dire potable oui on peut faire
c'est karo kann il peut il peut il peut
éviter les greens faible avec la gambie
dame alors cette position assez quoi tu
va nous dire une nouvelle fois avec le
bon fourgon foucault voilà donc mauvais
fou il ya une case intéressante en raid5
une case intéressante en d5 donc la case
des cinq parlement est évidemment
intouchable la case f5 est toujours là
donc cavalier 2
g3 est un plan légèrement supérieur aux
blancs pour les blancs cette position
attention les noirs veulent peut-être
essayé d'échanger les dames avec dom g4
je pense c'est l'idée de ce coup
d'annecy 8 mai les finales sont toujours
un petit peu inférieur avec cet avantage
peut-être des espaces peut-être qu'il va
essayer de faire à 4 ouvrir la colonne a
du coup c'est lui qui aura la tension
voilà cailloux du kg 3 si on est sur le
classique les échecs c'est toujours une
question de cases à l'ailé à deux doigts
d'être mieux il à deux doigts d'être
mieux l'a fait mieux il est là il a une
position il a une position à travailler
après les noirs ils ont quand même aussi
des choses à faire valoir dans le sens
où ils sont solides n'y a pas vraiment
de faiblesses
les noirs essaye de jouer dès 5h moment
c'est l'idée on l'accueille et g3 je
m'attends à quel g3a tempo tant qu'il
veut mettre le foin f8 aussi oui mais au
delà il bouge la tour pour pouvoir
libérer cette case la fuite pour le flou
et pour faire éventuellement g6 parce
que quand le cavalier en g3 et qu'on
joue j'ai six cavaliers n'a plus de
cases ça affaiblit droit mais le
cavaliere a plus de cases donc c'est
donnant donnant qui prend il reprend de
quoi tu penses de ces pour liquider long
de la colonne c ou de à pour essayer
dans les leaders si tu prends de ces
études la case des cinq faire très
attention à ça moi je pense il va
prendre 2 à la tout à fait logique pas y
prendre 2 s'est en fait je serais
vraiment complètement symétrique et à un
peu les mauvaises pièces combat et tu
prends de ces l'autre joue qu'à laisser
trois et il va tarf où j'ai cinq cas
elle prend tout prend même si ce qui a
aidé 5
ouais ben non c'est fini le ccc comme un
peu la partie de carlson contre tard il
récemment aux richesses incroyables
cette partie d'ailleurs ces voix là
c'est juste une seule case qui fait la
différence sur une partie donc là
apprend b5 et on nous propose dans le
chat des quatre un certain 333 normand
c'est l'idée peut-être après c'est
bizarre ce coup c b1 s'éprend bessin
puisque ça ouvre la colonna
bon tout cas ça rime qui réfléchit et
qui réfléchit longtemps
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que c'est
prendre apprend b5 paris c'est logique
et du coup il part sur ses preuves et 5
et s'était laissé tomber 5
voilà je suis vraiment étonné alors
qu'elle et ses trois peut-être qu'il
veut doubler sur la colonne sais mais ça
parait étrange
as-tu serait déjà en train de chanter là
c'était toi qui joues et après s'éprend
b5
non mais c'est vraiment bizarre ces
problèmes cinq chaînes pas perdre contre
les champs cops du genre et qui avait
qualifié trois fous j'ai cinq en tout
cas le plan et loisel et c3 il va il va
forcément essayer de mettre la double
doublé sur la colonne c'est sûr alors
peut-être que mais ce que c'est
dangereux si fait qu'ali ses trois tours
ces sept fous j'ai ceinture une variante
au hasard un tour ses huit dames des
genres admettons telles qu'aller en
l'air oui oui oui excusez moi désolé
alors peut-être un cahier ces trois cas
et des cinq je sais pas avec la case c6
attend à voir il a joué je vais je vais
arrêter d'analysé il ajoute t il ces
trois écoutes alors là la voilà je
m'attends chambre pour ces sept cas
validé cinq peut-être c'est peut-être ça
qui l'embêtent et après tu mets une tour
en c6 donc c'est à dire que tara c'est
toi qui est un filtre en premier avec
cette case for temps ces six là on a un
gros problème pour les noirs c'est qu'il
va y avoir une case qui va qui va être
fou g5 et la menace là c'est clair net
coup j'ai 5 c'est l'idée ouais vous les
5 c la menace stratégique fortin avec
fougue bref si ce qui est des cinq et ça
c'est quasi gagnant déjà donc peut-être
que sar il faut penser à tour c'est
cette quête des cinq mais il a raté qui
a aidé 5 en fait il n'y a pas vu ce tour
c'est 6 donc je vais montrer ce dont tu
parles pour être concret c'est ça la
variante tour celle-ci je suis allé plus
vite que ouais c'est pas grand chose
parce que tu fais pas grand-chose
dictator ans et 6 mais c'est quand même
toi qui mène les débats donc c'est
toujours plus facile à jouer avec les
avec les blancs qu'avec les noirs c'est
très pénible en blitz a joué en tout cas
la lettre en langue tu fais à 5 trouve
notre jeu mes envies de ses chiens ouais
c'est une sacrée épine dans la comédie
il a fait rage 6 écoute il empêche
rouges et 5 à witch's bien joué bien
joué à chis médias le même thème l'inca
et des 5 c la même en couleur c'est
untel c'est l'idée de cette ligne 1 à 3
aussi souvent de jouer sur les cases
blanches
en échange les pièces de casques blancs
le fou les fous de cases blanches et
après on met ce qu'avait demandé cinq
kits a doublé ses pions mais après on
insiste sur cette caste c6 peut-être
c'est intéressant de commencer par h3
attend deux tours c'est celle qui a aidé
5 provoquer les changements en c1 est
comme ça on a la même position en ces
temps et gagner le h3 hier ils le jouent
eux mêmes idées mais mêmes idées mais
petit gagne un tempo parce qu'il peut
pas bouger sa tour alors lui va sûrement
pas à jouer tour d7000 est un coude
dames et eux provoquer le cas validé
cinq quoi j'imaginerais c'est à peu près
ça et pourquoi je crois important ici
demande chasseurs m killers un jour il
aura pas de matchs du couloir
voilà exactement je croise aller vite le
mode du couloir sa contrôler la cage des
cas tu sais c'est que du bonus
voilà c'est pas un affaiblissement ici
il n'ya pas de y'a pas de première
partie important attend quand même c'est
bord bien rentrés dans le match pour
maxime
oui avec les blancs en particulier on a
une partie de haut niveau en lasser une
partie qui pourrait très bien avoir lieu
en partie langues
enfin voilà c'est parti
kasumi quelque chose quoi s'est passé
par une partie de café
là on a deux joueurs qui jouent leur
ligne théorique et qu'ils réfléchissent
aux moments importants
mais c'était réfléchi plus vite c'est
maxime qui a émis de plus il joue très
bien ses positions et du coup elle peut
elle peut être compliqué pour sa nature
ses six donc voilà alors ni et l'accueil
des 5 forcé à tempo at on pensé à cela
il prend la possession qu'il a lâché la
colonne sait mais il apprend la comédie
blake possession de la colonne a avec
cette rupture à 3,4 là il prend
l'avantagé
il prend davantage parce que ce cavalier
c'est les terribles tu peux pas prendre
des 5
voilà on a on a une très bonne position
pour les blancs après il va falloir la
travailler encore et ce qu'on peut
tenter un dame de damas deux faces là
pour le mans il ya un problème est que
lecavalier mais est ce que ça peut être
un plan de la qualité
ça va être compliqué de se débarrasser
de ce problème le cavalier d'accord donc
c'est un plan mais qui est pas vraiment
réalisable ici alors là il peut jouer
l'autre l'aude n'a pas trop de coups un
rouage 2g 3g de ses gains tempo alors
après comment faire pour faire rentrer
la dame aïcha d'alger quatre mois
peut-être g4 ce que t'es pas trop faible
mais bon après j'ai 4 qu'est ce que tu
fais j'écarte de f5 peut-être g4 2005 et
g4 roigé 3h le roi gk3 g3 g4 g5
ouais ouais ouais aussi où c'est trop à
manger 4 août affaiblit un peu et ce qui
peut avoir des d4 aussi des cats tout à
fait normal comme quoi très bons coups
des quatre dames des dames dr pour vite
revenir voilà c'est du coup qui voulait
faire depuis longtemps d'éclat dame a
quitté aussi s'il le fait il peut
maintenant s'installer en b3 et une
diagonale beaucoup plus intéressante
était comme ça tu es proche du raid bkt
à cisco b4 et a6 est peut-être le plan
ça peut être tour à 4 damas deux
justement
ouais mais bon ça défend un pour le mans
côté noir mais il défend très bien et
défend très bien
sa dalle en baisse est elle couvre à 6
elles couvraient vii elle est allée à
l'attack des 5 alors prise prise d'amd
sinclar il la joue vraiment technique
apprise prise je la gagne est un pion
est-ce que ça va suffire
pas sûr que ça suffise à 1,4 ou qui ont
trouvé cinq tours b 6 ces berges 4 1 il
avait vu depuis longtemps en plus ça et
le roi il est long à courber s'ils
savent faire peut-être temps v6 tu peux
pas faire ton attend si sa part pas
avant
vous prend le chien prend ou à 5-5 6 is
ou des six amérique 2 1 en mai des deux
tu pèses tu perds d'un quart des 4 et 4
nuls
des quatre nuls ouais il ay les
laissez-passer la ham il a très bien
joué et sarina il a bien défendu
j'ai c'est cela l'exercice f5 mesa ba
ouais on envoie le pion à y répètent ils
pouvaient envoyer deux pions f5
ouais bon alors attends c'est un peu
chaud parce qu'il n'y a plus qu'une
seconde pour sarine
allawi frôla c'est n'importe quoi c'est
ben c'est du délire pendule ouais ouais
c'est bizarre on s'y attendait pas à la
finale rentrée on pensait nul tranquille
et ce maxime va la jouer un sale la
rivale à jouer il va la jouer les
gagnants je pense peut-être maintenant
attention il peut bouger la tour
essaient de pousser le pion le problème
c'est que pour la droite pour gagner ce
option gkp sur toute la baroque
elle est incroyable le pion g4 il en
arêtes 3 et on arrête 3 tout seul et
well as et on en est tout proche d'un
gain reste bien jouer tourbe et de
tomber ça qui va faire les chèques des
espions 17
alors attention à la berd dont
l'éruption ça peut se retourner là
l'euro est passé
c'est terrible entouré fin pour la
famille va bouger la tour simplement way
est ton rêve de tour des trois noms des
trois tours f3 il va la perdre alors roi
c'est cette hyper anne ont ils peur
c'était pas bien joué au final le tour
est fait un tour f2 il c'est mal me
latour
ben ouais non mais là il est là il a
complètement craqué il a laissé passer
l'euro alors qu'il était gagnant
ouais
elle fait mal ça là où la la la la la la
haye contre contre le cours du jeu quand
même c'est bien mais il va falloir faire
gaffe parce que quand tu perds une
partie comme ça j'aime pas tu vas
rentrer dans un match comme ça ouais bah
qui proposent déjà de mettre 24 heures
de balle à maxime cclat au la finale
deux tours spiro serait pas content là
une seconde à la pendule c'est terrible
elle a tourné au moment où le roi est
passé way pour prendre j'ai carette
récré les plus haut placés en plus tu
sais ce qu'ils ratent un moment est venu
de faire de reculer la tour et que m la
tour sur la cinquième qui bloquent
totalement le roi est en fait après il
va pouvoir pousser son pion et je pense
que bon après ça allait très vite me
semblait qu'il y avait seulement
c'est dommage mais après avec si peu de
temps la lucidité qui parent alors
est-ce qu'on a les bons scores alors
c'est pas moi qui met les scores 1-0
tiens c'est marrant parce que le gars
qui fait les scores de chasse comme il a
mis 1 0 pour sarine mais il a marqué le
point bull est quoi un n'a pas tort au
final maxime qui joue ce slave
ok il a fait une cambridge esprit murray
j'aime paroisse position avec les noirs
balle assez compliqué j'ai en fait c'est
la question ils jouent pas ils jouent
pas sont ouvertes soit principal la
grüne tel qu'il adore jouer en anglais
de saïda il est injouable dessus est ce
que tu penses que c'est un choix en cela
une slave au début comme ccnucc land
bridge semble avoir eu des quatre des
cinq c4 c6 cambridge avec la cambridge a
fait partir oui oui ah oui bien sûr
parce que je voulais parler toi qui
disais pas cela à 6,6 et une cela oui
oui on est d'accord c'est assez contre
cornetto oui mais cet homme va prendre
un bateau si ça ça va aller très vite
faut pas trop parler dans le tchat avec
les gens qui n'ont pas de démo temps
c'est forcément très utile t'embête pas
c'est pas forcément très utile
ça troll tech a annoncé ta évident à
jouer ce que c'est assez passif donc ça
c'est que ça ressemble pas du tout
hostile de maxime matcher qui livre les
bonnes soirées saïd abadou on a besoin
de ces commentaires les analyses comme
théoriquement c'est quand même le patron
c'est une seule islam
du coup il va ya voir torse et 8.8 1
j'imagine avec les noirs exactement
donc j'aime bien la dore avoir les
mauvaises pièces est vrai que ces fous
sont pas rayonnant il doit être content
après ses solides atouts c'est tout si
on a affaire bien avoir les mauvaises
pièces il aime bien avoir des ressources
comme bon c'est vrai que c'est très
solide mais alors comment il va position
blanche et à ses selles tu peux tu peux
essayer de petit à petit améliorée ta
position en essayant de pousser allal el
dame peut-être avec un 4b 4 si on peut
essayer de doubler sur la colonne ces
puits les noirs en fait ne peuvent pas
toucher aux ruptures ils peuvent pas
jouer 5 peuvent pas jouer ces cinq il
prépara du coup double et 6 pour
contrôler la casse ces cinq c'est vrai
qu'on veut pas que les blancs met un
cavalier en c5 qui serait très ennuyeux
donc b6 mais du coup maintenant ça
l'affaiblît le pion c6 mais il est bien
couvert il est bien couvert mais on a
une possibilité de l'attaquer cinq fois
quasiment avec les blancs c'est à dire
en doublant sur la colonne c'est en
jouant cavalier 5 et en jouant une
demande à 4 donc il joue c'est sain
c'est aussi quand il s'activait 5 pour
essayer d'égaliser très rapidement il me
semble que les images aux quelques coups
un peu long larroy g25 sembler bizarre
c'est bien joué la part de maxime bas
prix là c'est à pas grand chose dedans
juste échange les dames détroit qui a
valu b2 qui a et c quatre et ça va pour
les blancs pas j'en ai rejoué des
millions des partis comme ça
ouais non là les noirs ils ont réglé
leur problème
ya que si tu installes lecaillon ces
quatre noms que ça peut être pénible
oui ça aurait installé aux usa devrait
rester in cape est impressionnant il n'a
pas il a pensé que c'est trop facile je
pense de garder davantage
ouais c'est clair et d'alliages aussi
l'ajout de trois coups un peu long et il
a traîné quoi alors qu'elle est une
bonne position
est ce que ça peut même se retourner
cette histoire enfin voir de maxime ah
oui s'il commence à pas échanger les
dames peut-être mal me semble que john
crombez huit baies 3 s'avère très très
solide les blancs vont sur les normes
vont essayer de faire peut-être des
trucs à 5 à 4 pour essayer d'échanger on
devrait avoir un échange complet des
pions l'ale dame pour tomber dans une
finale nul l'a7 lwin cette ligne me
paraît assez logique
si les change pas les dames attention
attention coll il est chargé b3 alors là
on a un schéma classique en s'attend à 5
à 5 qui va faire vivre le fou en quelque
sorte aussi quand tu fais à 5 à 4
justifie ton flou et donc la suite très
très attendu oui j'ai pas compris
pourquoi sarine a gagné la première
partie belle a réussi à faire à faire le
con tre jeu avec ses pions en bétonnant
exactement donc à 5 jouer l' énorme
avance autant pour maxime
donc évidemment s'il a des opportunités
de mettre la pression autant il va le
faire vieux parti d'avant où il a quand
même réussi à leur tour hier
l'opposition légale mais ça s'est
retourné contre lui après un web malgré
la défaite mais ça veut dire que le
temps n énorme importance
c'est à dire que 7 minutes d'avancé
quand même le lui permet de gagner
beaucoup de parties égales
après il va falloir commencer à mettre
la marche avant parce que
ni al sarine et un spécialiste des
parties bullet
j'aimerais pas qu'on rentre à égalité
dans les bulles est ce serait bien que
maxime est quand même un petit matelas
d'au moins 2,3 points en asie maxime va
faire très très mal en trois minutes
c'est sa meilleure cadence à trois plus
c'est les rues gagne tous les speechs sc
là où il est il est clairement dans leur
les deux trois meilleurs joueurs du
monde sur cette cadence ou 20 minutes il
peut perdre plus de partis parce que du
coup les gens le temps de les
adversaires autant comme de pouvoir de
voir venir ce serait agressif c'est très
intéressant
il peut essayer de trouver des aides et
des réseaux un pc 3d réseau mais
attention à se fiancer 5 carrés qui
coûte ours et 8 pour le moment est hors
service mais c'est un peu passif pour
ses 8 n'est pas partisan du coup après
c'est autre chose que ce qu'on peut
clouer aussi on peut peut-être clouer le
fou le cavalier icloud et 5
mais bon ça a pas l'air si embêtant que
ça pour les ormes un simple fait croire
attention à moi je crois quand même je
les ai vus en même temps que toi
après aussi l'activité joutes hors ces
huit ok ça va pas être le coup préféré
maxime où la cavalière 4 bien jouer
attaque 6 pouces et 4 qui arrive
attention à tous ses pions pendant ce
cavalier qui va faire très mal avec ses
deux tours c'est cet essai huîtres est
passible
donc là on a clairement un avantage pour
les blancs qui devrait doubler sur la
colonne dès maintenant
ouais mais je pense ça tiens encore un
pour les noirs ah je pense
stratégiquement là on est dans le nez
une position quasiment flou trop cuit
3,8 alors mais ça c'est trop passif
ouais il ya toujours foule et 5 sur 8
mai par exemple lalala stratégiquement
terrade tu as une faiblesse en c5 une
autre en a cinq
une autre de 6 une hauteur de 5,4
faiblesse 0 faiblesse sur les blancs ça
ne va pas bon allez on y croit on y
croit allez on y croit
il va il va nous arnaque il a deux
minutes trente d'avancé donc y joue
compliquer la position c'est la décide
de partir sur ce cette idée là il va
faire quoi bush sont fondées 8 peut-être
ont des 8 ou 9 8
on est fluide peut-être pour faire
attention s'ils arrivent à faire ces
quatre c'est lui qui va passer mieux et
ce qui a valu en dessin qui n'est pas
stable ag as.g donc les menaces c4 à huy
lecavalier a peut pas revenir dessus en
plus il a pas de chemin pour l'atteindre
il va faire quoi peut-être tour ses
cadres du coin avec les blancs ouais
tour ses quatre tours sekkat on peut
doubler sur la colonne des peut-être
faut calculer tour des 8 es ce que 4 et
un coût mais qu'at-il apprendre et jouer
doublé peu importe
et tout reprend 1,5 a remis au cas par
cas lorsque je peux jouer fouet le bois
d'ordre hockey non pardon par explique
le jeu eux quatre aussi le 4 à 1,4 ça
laissera la case f4 mais bon quand même
son roi il est faible
ok joue autour des 6 il a dû voir un
truc à peut-être eu qu'à appuyons prend
tout reprend airoise 6,6 ayaka relief 4
encore alors web cinq filets à est fini
tout reprend des six evra prend 1,4
hayatou aussi son corps a du coup il
faut des 6es attend au moins des
prairies non c'est gagner c'est gagner à
bien jouer max un look qui comprend pas
ce qui était très bien fait c'est faire
retrouver ça a pris trois coups un ouais
parce qu'il avait une très très bonne
position lot
alors on à combien on a combien de temps
de jeu là pour se faire un avis il ya
déjà eu 23 minutes
23 minutes de jeu un partout ça veut
dire qu'il reste encore il reste encore
six sept partis dans la cadence par
maxime on repart avec son un échange ils
jouent pas cavalier prend un 2e tour
prend 1,2 pourtant il y avait une très
très bonne position
il joue là une principale donc là c'est
très connu et bien voyez qu'elle allait
des cinq est une idée qui arrivent pour
les blancs suivi de ces 4 1 4 aussi
plusieurs plans possibles fait longtemps
que j'ai plus joué cette ligne k et
dessins croqués c'est le coup logique
donc toujours un peu la même idée on se
double les pions ne s'est pas un
programme comprend on prend l'espace et
on l'a vu comme dans la partie
précédente c'est très dur un jeu pour
les noirs puis on joue aussi bons fous
contre le mauvais font elles bon fou
contre le mur est fou toujours avec ce
pion des six qui est toujours faible
on va voir qui fait quoi expliquer et
des cats et une au break avait quatre
c'est une option est souvent mais
problème c'est que ce pion des cats est
faible et toujours des cinq effort est
sa seule différence juste visuellement
on voit bien en fait t'as un fou qui
joue bien puisque et sur case noire et
les pions sont sur blanc et puis celle
inverse de l'autre côté quoi et puis
surtout à la rupture à 4 alors cuilapa
leur rupture à 5 aussi vrai que c'est
plein de petits plein de petites pointes
qui sont embêtantes il a fait cavalier à
7 du coup cavaliers à cet om l a4 oui
c'est ici s'il prend 6,6 alors il me
semble que ça c'est théorique nous
semble que vas tu aies joué une partie
contre et signer le sida dessus je me
rappelle plus trop quand maxime qui joue
plus vite un dans toutes les parties
prendre l'aventage autant il a l'air
d'être un peu plus fort quand même
maximin sur sur les deux premières
parties ouais ils feront tout de suite
une à deux minutes d'avancé après les 30
premiers coups c'est très très très
important banyan sarine et pourrait pour
te dire il ya une sécurité renforcée
pour cet événement il ya deux caméras
chez les joueurs il ya une caméra
frontale c'est le convoi mais aussi une
autre caméra
pour les arbitres qui est une caméra par
derrière pour voir leurs écrans caméras
qu'ils ont envoyée à chaque joueur ouais
je pense oui il ya deux caméras yahia la
vue frontale sur le joueur et il ya une
vue pour l'arbitrage par derrière on
voit bien l'écran voit bien à bien le
bien les joueurs voilà il assez v5 avait
cinq à 5,1 la saynète c'est un pion pas
ses protégés c'est un gros avantage
c'est un an déjà embarqué c'est énorme
ce pion pas ses protégés oui même si le
pion beckett est un peu faible en a
quelque chose d'énorme
donc il est blanc et noir c'est de jouer
des 5
mais le problème c'est que l'opinion
s'inquiète en l'air qu'il faudrait
qu'ils protègent 6 pts est elle si ce
que ça peut leur trop affaiblie sans
presse que des quatre pattes une idée
pour les blancs alors là on peut pas
arriver mais on n'est pas pressé voilà
l'idée c'est d'améliorer la position et
pourquoi pas de rentrer en finale donc
là j'avais lancé un damas mais je sais
pas ce que ça vaut à l'essai pendant mes
trois j'aime bien ça ça a empêché m 6
c'est plutôt pas mal collard et bien
jouer vrai ça contrôler cette case
attention cette casse des cinq est
toujours important donc pour le moment
ramener le cavalier suisse est un peu
dur mais ça pourrait arriver un jour ça
peut arriver un jour et surtout que ça
ça pose le problème de trouver des coûts
pour les noirs il n'y a pas de dessin
qui a pas de culo logique ya pas de m6
oui c'est évident c'était vital pour lui
de jouer des 5 c'était vraiment
important et ce cas-ci ce peut être une
idée pour avancer leurs pions on le
garde le plus longtemps qu'à regarder
avec la sicile va être fébrile le pion
ya trop de pièces pour le moment tu l'as
dans sa cale moment tu commences à
pousser un pion comme ça le plus tard
possible entre guillemets où il ya où il
ya un truc vraiment qui te fait un
signal quoi je j'envoie mon pion au
final de roi je le pousse
d'accord donc tu es change vraiment où
tu te le gardes là et c'est vraiment
quand quand tu te sens c'est la mode à
ce qui est plus forte que l'exécution
donc en fait tant que l'option est là
les noirs ne peuvent pas trop bouger
donc son biais de rester focus sur ce
pion donc en fait je vais commencer à le
bouger si les noirs commencent à essayer
d'attaquer mais pions b 4 en finale deux
tours par exemple et là évidemment je
pousse mon pire on disjoncte eu le pouce
quand tu sens vraiment que ça fait la
diff quoi ouais il est très bien et très
bien le pion donc ça c'est un super
avantage pour maxime donc les noirs leur
avantage mais serait la majorité
centrale puisqu'ils sont à deux contre
un mais comme comme on l'a vu ils
peuvent pas pousser
parce que dès qu'ils poussent 5 qui
tombe et voir si c'est interdit par la
dame et ya paroisse h8 parce qu adam
prend f7 donc c'est est-ce que du
ku'damm e6 peut être une idée c'était
que quand même d'un jeu si ce n'est du
coup la teuf ouais c'était terrible de
cisco et après il peut aussi simplement
jouer pour c'est un tour ces deux
doublés sur la colonne s'est il va
rentrer en finale
clairement avantageuses niall qui
réussit pas à tenir la cadence du joueur
français alain la lie à trois minutes
d'écart après un coup là c'est terrible
c'est cette jeune ya très peu de doute
sur l'issue de cette partie là quand
même trois fuites donc voilà il est gris
s'est quand même rendu compte de son
erreur il va essayer de faire des cinq
préparait physis n 6 dé 5 c'est vraiment
la base
maxime pourrait même jouer en termes dé
5,1 oui pour rejoindre d'amd 5 qu'elle a
très fort pour être doublée sur la
colonne s'est il est parti pour doubler
beaucoup de bons plans alors ne vous
méprenez pas sur le temps de réflexion
de dennis al sarine c'est sûr que ça ça
veut dire qu'il en difficulté en 5 plus
simple mais c'est un excellent joueur de
bullet qui jouera complètement différent
différemment 1 + 1 et donc qu'il sera
extrêmement dangereux là il faut pas se
méprendre par rapport à ça et se dire
que dans une cadence très très rapide il
sera très lent ce sera pas le cas il
faut vraiment faire l'écart maintenant
il faut se ferait qu' requêtes qui
démarre au moins à plus de plus 300 l'a
déjà dit pour être sûr de gagner je
pense fo qui démarrera plus
5 + 6 pour tuer le suspense quoi bon
haletant dom vayssette
là c'est très compliqué là les coûts
sont très simples ah c'est pas si tout
ça c'est très très très passifs alors
est tellement envie de faire un cavaleur
ces 2 3 des 5 mais pour le moment on n'a
pas trop le temps ou trois ce qui va les
manger peut s'installer en d5 ce match
du couloir manquez pas une menace mais
faut faire attention
le foot la double crise vitam des cinq
as l'air intéressante peut-être y
gardent la tension tout reprend ces deux
vieilles dames français 2 je pense qu'il
va essayer de jouer des coups simples
l'adversaire de prendre une décision
véritablement la dame là n'en faut le
prendre la dame ouais je gagne la
colonne il reprend la tour e quai les
deux les deux options étaient sur la
table après ouais lives un petit coup de
main petits pions moche tu vas partir à
un moment quand même pour éviter ces
vagues du couloir certainement temps h 3
ou même en h4 pour prendre l'espace h4
[Musique]
après il défend pas mal hein sarine
depuis janvier il faut que maxime quand
même soit plus agressifs les jours il a
été un peu passif sur certains coups va
falloir qu'ils lui rentre un peu dans
hannah il va falloir faire la différence
peut-être un coup comme tour c'est un
pur goudam b3 essayé de le mettre mal
aux torts mais la dame b3 d'apps et 3
c'est l'idée après il fait un peu ce
dont il a le secret maximin c'est lui
qui a la science un de savoir jouer des
coups en blitz qui d'accord mais qu'elle
sait ça allait très bien joué dame ces
trois quais des 5 1 c'est l'idée je
pense y mille cavaliers bloqueurs en a6
écoute je trouve qu'il joue très bien ça
arrive vraiment en défense ils défendent
un carré bloqueurs c'est super donc pour
ces huit ici mais maxime va lui faire le
cake c3 qui est des 5 1 maxime et c'est
ce qu'on avait prévu il ya longtemps
il a la possibilité de le faire
attention qui a laissé trois courses et
8 qu'il ya des cinq impossible un petit
hameau 6 peut-être d'impôt 6
ouais mais un v6 f4 encore c'est
peut-être pas fait c'est peut-être pas
fini il y aura bien joué faux b6 est là
il y avait cinq du coup voilà qu'elle
prend des cinq aussi les lie à tous qui
adam civic enfin deux variantes pris ce
prix du parc laval y en a six bon live à
conclure alors je pense qu'il va les
manger des cinq plus tôt en tout cas
maximois est vraiment c'est vraiment
fort quand même ce qui fait un de
réussir à maintenir l'attention le met
un peu plus mal autant et après ce pré
score et se presse pas il vient mettre
le coup de grâce
ces sept
je m'attendais à tout repenser 8 mai
c'était peut-être un missclick un
d'ailleurs possible puisque là il ya
d'amsterdam f 4 1 qui est pénible on l'a
pas on l'a pas dit verbalement mais il
ya eu mal joué je dois reculer la double
pression qui est une énorme erreur
maxime le tout repenser 8 et casser
cette saga nié tout de suite puisque la
dame était ans et 8 et non pas en c6 est
maintenant plongé en train de se faire
retourner la faire très attention des
quatre alors à temps et ce qui réussit
par un miracle à attaquer ici il a raté
qu'a réalisé 8 c'est incroyable ça quand
même incroyable au match ça c'est
rarissime à ce niveau là c'est de rater
une fourchette quand même royal avec une
minute 25 à la pendule incroyable
bonjour tu as fait n'importe quoi du
coup alors ça devrait gagner d'un v6
c'est fini le pion va à dame
attention encore à des dames à 4,1 sem
voilà la mêlée les échecs les échecs
arrive là tu vas perdre beaucoup trop de
matériel à six dames à cette dame des
117 la dame à huit dames assises d'un v6
d'un v8 c'est fini ouh la la la la la la
pression qu'eux
l'évaluation a dû beaucoup bougé un
voile adams essaie t dmb 8,6 de chercher
à le tenir oui attention quand même hein
il faudra pas en rater trop souvent des
fourchettes comme ça ouais bon après il
a quand même dominé les trois parties
mais attention il pourrait y avoir un
3-0 propres et c'est quand même bon mais
après la tellement d'avancé autant ça
sent plutôt bon dans la perspective du
marché dans les trois plus un qui arrive
etc
mais quand même mais quand même il va
falloir faire attention parce que parce
que sarine défend bien l'hôte des fonds
très très bien il est solide en défense
et est aussi dans cette cambridge prime
on n'avait pas trop aimé ans la première
à position donc quatre échanges
il essaie d'être un peu plus agressif
bien joué le 4 5 et 4 6 1 ce plan
classique ça casse forte design qui
cherchent à endormir mvl sournoise
tactique pour pas qu'ils essaient de les
endormir tout cas il a accéléré un
sarine on voit qu'il a qu'il a fait un
petit un petit changement la tue aussi
un jeu rendre compte comme nous que qui
peut pas qui peut pas rester que si peu
de temps à la pendule
on nous dit le road to 3150 en même
temps il en avait il a déjà gagné une
place et ricky commencé avec moins de
l'eloxatine il a dépassé presque le 5 +
1 et 3 + 1 ça compte
oui oui oui les 2 cas lance ces deux cas
dans ce but elle peut arriver à 3106 ça
se passe bien donc allée b 6
si l'implant la région net comme
cinquième but en 26 matchs et entrant
riquet des six mais oui on met le plus
honnête la peur leur poisson qu'ils
lobby
l'écoutille bois un petit peu je ne vois
pas là car en même temps mais il a pas
eu de moi il a du compte quand même sur
la colonne des mais bon et ça va pas
suffire à 1 c'est un des dogmes piolenc
là c'est un énorme pot il est dans le
dur un bon après c'est peut-être pas si
simple de gagner avec les blancs non
c'est pas simple bon ben ok c'est sympa
c'est vraiment agréable qu'elle et ses
seins il faut prendre un grand b kata
kata 5 puis tu prépares b5 et même quand
tu perds des 4 à la fin tard à ce pion
bessette qui sera très faible sur place
appareil de ligne avec bing qui
arriverait il ya un schéma de jeu assez
simple pour les blancs c'est pas faux
kaïs et 5 j'aime bien ré diary le juin
il joue là sa force beaucoup de choses
et puis poussé 5 2 et 5 des kata kata
cinq là on va le voir aux couleurs à non
ça va arriver ça va faire très mal il va
jouer sur le bon fou contre le mauvais
fond a une nouvelle fois ouais en plus
c'est ça il a marqué l'un joker qui peut
perdre un pion voire même de il sera
encore sera exact oui il n'ya pas de
contre jeu pour maxime d'ailleurs maxime
il veut pas il veut ils cherchent une
autre option 1 que la prise à sa fille
avant on prend ces cinq c'était plaisant
mais n'oblige et aidara 8 damas huit
hockey vont mal et va préparer
paisiblement sa poussée et sa prise
espace à 4 b 4 à 5 alors là pour le mans
il peut pas le jouer un quart pour tours
1 pour un 4 500 royal voit ces deux
tournois qui servent à rien tu as signal
sarine égalise maintenant voilà c'est
pas encore fait mais 2,2 après les
quatre premières parties maxime aurait
eu davantage mais
mais tu vois égalité au score et l'autre
tient bien parti cette première partie
fait très mal pendant ce temps la
pendule tourne et on se rapproche du
bullet
moi je dis ça je dis rien mais la
pendule a joué en faveur de sarine les
seconds à l'objectif mon avis c'est
d'avoir de gagner un petit peu le 5 + 1
de massacrer 3 + 1 et après de survivre
alors il l'a si la jouer tes parents à
trois corps humain veut il va jouer avec
tours c4 pour ces quatre lots préparés
sa poussée de pions mais il a tu
reprends des cartes il a dû calculer b3
j'imagine voilà ça va être son idée avec
la dame qui pourra pas rester connecté à
la tour on prendrait quatre baies 3
cependant aurait plein de petits trucs
n'aurait pas un b 6 ça changerait adam
dessin mo5
c'est dans le même truc mais là
simplement les cinq listes des prises la
finale qu'on veut pas là oui mais bon ça
simplifie donc attention si petite
finale deux tours qui peut arriver
puisque foule 8 et ce pion b5 certains
blocus quand même le pion à 4 a du mal à
passer
donc plutôt une bonne version là pour
maxime l'a manqué de précision le sarine
est-ce que tour ces trois ça peut être
une idée pour faire quoi pour défendre
les pions et à la mairie ces trois b 4
pour ces trois b4 très très fort ça je
comprends tout reprend et le pion b3 et
fixé c'est pas agréable le roi 7 et 6
c'est vraiment très actif à jouer que
dans un monde idéal j'aurais voulu
mettre la tour quelque part sur la
troisième et ramener le roi
regardez oui bien sûr pourquoi pas mais
ce sont ces mieux pour les blancs alors
comment comment on peut faire ça côté
blanc parce que tour c'est 8 on est
d'accord ça aucun intérêt side 7
aucun vote lui dès ce four de 8 en avait
déjà parlé il est toujours agréable dans
ses positions et contrôler les recettes
il contrôle sept cases 17
il permet au roi de passer en sept des
huit s'en soucier de ses pions classique
dans les sicilienne on a froid on a un
droit
qu'ils s'activent rapidement côté noir
un flou qui empêche à 4 une tour bien
placé et les blancs réussissent pas à ça
gens c'est assez marrant parce que
visuellement tu vas premier coup d'oeil
tu dis bon les blancs ça va aller tu vas
tu vas trouver un moyen d'avancer le
pion jusqu'en assises quoi genre si tu
es un espion à 6 c'est fini mais c'est
pas si facile leur tête le tour c'est
huit tours à huit ouais c'est un truc
auquel j'ai pensé web b4 la b4
hyperactif bécane j'aime beaucoup
à quatre tours des trois diapasons hso
kébé 4 il veut faire quoi torah 5 et
fois km il veut mettre un pion g4 pour
refermer ce roi là bas c'est très actif
pour ensuite affaiblir le bureau 5 avec
un projet 4-1 pas de f4 donc là il va
jouer j'ai kata tempo le maximum le col
et je m'attends au g4 à il pourra avoir
un jour un réseau de fou c'est ouais
c'est que ça c'est la défense à qui
étourdit 1 d'abord ok c'est là l'ami d
une fois que tu fais g4 avec la tour en
verre là si jamais un jour il ya fou qui
arrive lancé si c'est fini c'est
maintenant c'est très bien joué en
tassant c'est la force de maxime défense
active toujours pour 1,5
attention pour tous 1 / f4 tu veux quoi
à la f4 g4 le plonger 3 devient très
faible où il prend qui imprimerait
bizarre moi j'aime pas du tout ce coup
bizarre un g4 est très très fort ouais
c'est étonnant c'est un danger catway ça
ça permettait de réseauter leroy
abeilles étaient même plus ou moins bien
là il était enfin c'était complètement
égal ouais la petite faute en de maxime
le g4 à peine du coup là il est bon
c'est toujours proche d'égalité parce
que le pion attention foule deux fronts
v5 c'est l'idée ouais mais il voudra fou
prend et on reprend à trois exactement
on attend cette finale est sûrement car
vente possible qu'elle soit perdu alors
pour quoi
certes le roi va vite arriver
accompagner le plan b et tu vas manger
fkt même quand tu manges f4 tu vas tu
vas pas réussir à pousser les pions et
du coup il peut aller aider la promotion
du pion b et on va le voir j'espère
enfin j'espère pas vraiment en mer pour
le public cette bizarre qui joue pas toi
5 ans reste il a joué quelques coups
pour récupérer du temps ouais là fut
prouvé ça comme ça va être
[Musique]
je comprends pas pourquoi il y va pas de
façon on n'a pas le choix
bon il y aura eu un roi des deux
pourquoi pas le roi mais là faut prouver
5 après maxime qui part pour le contrôle
de la d2 ou d3 essaie de contrôler au
maximum sarine
alors est ce qu il veut tenter un tour à
cette maxime qui revient et peut-être
tourasse mais ça mène à rien je lui dise
que tour à sept tours bessette et tout
mais je vois pas où ce à quoi ça mène
ok je vous libère l'activité c'est un
peu la même chose qu'avec ce sont les
foules au moins le même truc dont la
maintenance est complètement gagnant
mais c'était la même idée même idée que
ce que je pensais
mais là sauf que tu perds pas le pion à
3 donc les deux pions passé sont trop
forts et maxime va abandonner
c'est une vraie semble ans oui donc
c'est l'idée de sarine c'est l'idée
qu'on avait pas vu avec sap c'était de
ramener le roi ans et 5 pour pouvoir
faire
roy prend b5 et garder le pur à l'envi
en fait c'est fou hein tout ça ça
partent se coucher 4c quel dommage de
pas voir jauger 4 ce que le food on
revient un peu en fait jugé le 4 et de
manière assez étonnante maxime change de
premier coup je trouvais que les
espagnols se passait assez bien pour
maxime et il part dans l'anglais the
j'ai du mal à comprendre ce choix
stratégique dans l'ouverture seb est
très étonnant deux très très bonne
position une fois avec 4 minutes
d'avancé après un coup voilà on avait
deux massacres
alors est ce que il y cherche des
options pour la suite du match est ce
que l'idée c'est aussi un ensemble le
match et non il va revenir à ce set
en fait là il sait déjà qu'il est un
énorme ascendant psychologique sur 4,5
donc il peut y revenir en 3 + 1 et il
essaye de voir si l'autre connaît bien
ces ouvertures sur cette ligne très à la
mode
ouais ça permet ça permet d'ouvrir une
carte quoi entre guillemets exactement
pour savoir ce qui ce qui a là dessous
quoi donc l'appui on prend des 4 es fou
17 no 3
paris c'est ça leur laisse le pion et
après on joue des lignes avec fougue et
8 bat mathieu battu est un expert cette
ligne il est parti à mathieu on l'a trop
trop laid on l'a trop trembler il a
décidé de jeter l'épongé parfaitement je
vérifie ça et ces cons là encore avec
nous non là encore avec nous on l'a
encore avec nous ça va et bah qui est ce
que baky as que baky aussi là en cas de
la bac est parti ba qui nous a laissés
pour le moment il va vite revenir bien
vite revenir au quai du coup bon ça
c'est c'est une vendent assez connue qui
a été j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de fois
récemment c'est la vendée pour isoler
les noirs ou un peu de jeu mais c'est
jamais évident faut toujours éviter les
finales qui peuvent être très
désagréable
il faut donc trouver des contres jeu sur
le roi
ça me rappelle toujours que l'ati
toujours ta partie à stockholm contre
lui comme un modèle de jeu conclut pions
isoler ces terribles fou des trois ici
ou faut deux pour contrôler la casse g4
s'avérer importante attention foule des
ja cavaliers aux 4 tu peux par ok quand
même j'ai un sens que c'est sarine gère
beaucoup mieux ce type de position que
les positions après le 4-1 je pense que
maxime retournera leur à la dance r'n'b
jousse avec les blancs avec les enfants
il les connaît bien ses positions aya
fou g4s a fait ça quand tu n'as pas de
compte à part ok tu peux te retrouver
vite dans les villes dans les courants
d'air
alors qui va pouvoir le jouer alors vous
aussi ce fou prend un f6 généralement
vous pourrez penser vous pourriez penser
que c'est un très bon coup parce que sa
double les pions mais ça donne la paire
de fouet le roi noir se fera pas trop
attaquer il fera froid je suis 3g 8 et
c'est même plutôt les noirs qui vont
attaquer quoi genre tous deux sur trois
ce pion aux trois qui est très faible
après oui où
scipion était un rêve de foot pro 26 ans
une belle option mais là la plus du tout
donc à 3000 euros qu'est un avocat en
coups précédents on éprouvait rococo
précédente et un bon cours étonnant
c'est à trois dames c'est cette qui
empêche le rock mais bon après il peut
il peut tenter des droits f2 sur dame c
est peut-être ou même f4 un f4 c'est
typique aussi quatre verres que santa
lui remettrai la structure à l'endroit
non moyens train là je trouve que les
derniers coups de série n'aurait manqué
de punch et l'accueil des sept rouges et
quatre fois ci donne des huit ses
passifs à f4 va être intéressant c'est
vraiment beaucoup ça le cahier 17 et
dominer un oui et tu prépares des filets
tu meures à sa fille 5 1 7 5
je pense que maxime réfléchit beaucoup à
f/5 f4 il va le faire
là le seul truc c'est que les cavaliers
ou cinq noms c'était la force de f4
c'est que c'est bloqué ce cavalier qui
pourra rebondir peut-être verser 4 mai
après ouais
alors est ce que est ce que damas
j'avais à dire peut-être d'un match 4
mai avec quatre fait cavaliers sont fous
ces deux assez mal joué ce petit ruff
même pas ce tireur en dommage et le
carnet peut aussi revenir en c6
totalement repensé 6 à la tension
qu'elle et ses 6 peut-être
ok c'est 6 très fort ouais parce que le
foot va devoir quitter la diagonale adam
la venue en mai 6 et la dame jean bessis
soient bons enchaînements donc là tout
ça ça vient de ce petit coup le petit
rouquin au lieu de f4 qui empêchait la
manade du cavalier qui domine et c'est
dommage cette fourchette c'est
envisageable ya passé d' attaque sur le
roi il faut prendre achète déjà quand
y'a pas un cavalier g5 pour enchaîner
ouais faut vraiment qu'il ya plus de
matos ça peut être une idée mais là pour
le moment c'est trop trop loin voilà
position est pas catastrophique pour les
blancs non plus hein c'est juste qu'il a
raté l'occasion des égales mais il
semblait qu'il avait l'opportunité de
prendre un bel avantage sarine par le
blizzard 1 qui joue pas le dame b6
rapidement position quand même coup
assez assez logique at il réfléchi à
flouer cinq ici pour forcer des quatre
façon ou d'une autre mais fou et 5 fu en
et prend kébé 3,4 en blitz a peut être
un défaut que j'ai moi aussi c'est de
perdre trop de temps sur des choix comme
ça les deux choix vont tu peux peut-être
prendre 20 30 secondes dessus mais il va
y va griller une minute 30 1 quasiment
sûr sur ce choix seb et c'est
probablement une très mauvaise décision
là d'un point de vue pratique de la part
de sarine qui décide de jouer fou aux 5
il a mis combien de temps je la connais
dans tout pendant qu'elle provoque est
métro encaissé 4 e pour se caler ses
cartes d'amd 3g 6 seulement comme ça il
n'y aura pas des tours d un à cause de
cavaliers b2 peut être à g et gervasi
récents gains en d4
si le pion était en f2 je te dirais que
les blancs sont vraiment mieux voilà
bien sûr avec le pion à f3 seul champion
3 contrebalance quand même la faiblesse
des 5
c'est quand même un peu mieux agir vite
sur tout ce qui a aidé 4 face à ce flot
6 c'est quand même une belle option pour
les blancs mais alors est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment progressé le truc c'est que
sarine il est mal autant et qu'une
nouvelle fois maxime à mon avis va
partir sur le scénario de partie où il
joue des petits coups ils essayent de
maintenir l'attention et ils arnaquent à
la fin ni le match à l'air chaud l'écart
n'est pas fait ah oui le mal le match
est chaud il reste combien de temps il
reste trente huit minutes 50 dans cette
cadence donc l'écart sera pas fait avant
le 3 + 1 et on sait sarine for an à la
fin donc oui le match va être va être
tendu jusqu'au bout ça c'est sûr encore
2 minutes 30 d'avancé c'est énorme
ouais ça faire la différence ça inc a
pris une j'ai regardé après la prime
18,1 pour le foot 5 c'était trop vrai
beaucoup trop et là là ça va faire mal
ça va être ils jouent des coudes trop
long maxime va faire sa spécialité à
petit à petit améliorée la position il
améliore 3g cette côte et noir qui sert
pas forcément à grand-chose ans il joue
un coup on a maxime réfléchissez bien
c'est comme ça il peut proposer un
enchaînement de coups après france et
quatre souffrent ces cathos qui est pour
jouer qu'ils sont bons cavaliers contre
son mauvais fou puis on prend pour
prendre les empreintes d'al c3
c'est toujours un peu plus agréables
même six options c4 est quand même assez
bon à mes jeux cavaliers vraiment
rajoutant de beats alors il tente un
truc de beats en partie dont il se
serait pas le bon choix
là évidemment le cavalier en blitz est
quand même plus
agréable et il opte pour une finale où
il espère vraiment embêter les noirs
avec un carré les biens placés d'entrée
un écart bien placé mais voilà allait
bien pour les blancs quand même salle la
cale mieux pour les blancs puisque le
roi arrivant des quatre roues arrivant
des quatre pour moi c'est sûr qu'il va
la gagner ça là oui oui nos malades bien
sûr c'est trop trop agréable
alors comment il va y vas y va percer à
une seconde dix secondes 1,4 et peut
jouer à 4 à 5
hyper fort il a fixé en a 5 vous fixé en
dessin et que le choix entre prendre en
b5 aussi une option un oui oui là les
deux là il travaille va faire une
faiblesse l'ail puis après tout ça les
droits oui donc roi aussi s'il va jouer
avec 4 g4 une faiblesse en abscisse une
faiblesse en v5
car il va pousser les pions la f4 on s'y
attend f4 h44 c'est bien aussi
jusqu'à trafic at attention il doit pas
prendre bouger son cavalier
je reviens ici il va jouer g4 il va
jouer g5 à ce que les noirs ont intérêt
à jouer g5 eux mêmes mois il devait
jouer ce à quoi la très important je
pense oui cette fois ci sans trop le jeu
est stoppé cette majorité
la g5 ses classiques là dans les esprits
des changes ce g5 est tellement fort que
du coup ça te permet à temps pour eux
d'avoir une avancée il a pu m'en passer
voilà ici le cahier l'avenir angers 4
pour les en f6 pas mal d'options
ouais le pur achète et ses faiblesses
yahoo via ces trois des cinq là
énormément de choix seul truc qu'il faut
pas faire c'est changer de carélie
contre le fou on exactement il faut
garder son calme et il ya beaucoup plus
de ressources
bon assez 5 d'ici là le roi monte
lorsque vous 17 de cavale est bien en
dessin qui va venir en aide si on remet
loin des quatre pour empêcher à la
poussée du pion et kawéni ça on peut
monter le roi aussi la rue yvon entre le
roi pourquoi pourquoi jouer passif
attention à faire attention fouet si
samba guissé changer de 5 à 18 ans il va
devoir reculer
plett membres 6 les exemples droit
cavaliers akaïev 6 a gagné 3 calais
prend 8,3 bouge assez beau ça gagne à
yvan j'en achète il revient à attendre
et la madre revel à 1,7 à 2 707 et f5 et
fait mater en fait il fait mater bon tu
peux aussi juste faire le simple car l
idée 5 1 ouais mais là c'est la tête
thaksin va jouer 7,1 ou cavaliers pros 8
et f5 tugay ils calculent tard je
demande un truc est ce qu'on n'a pas eu
sa 3ème set carré hui 3.836 on réussisse
à gagner wes agréé la ccit qu'elle prend
vite la paix prend 8,3 pour lui 3 6 j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas le truc le
plus clean chimera c'est une énorme
pièce de sa gagne ça gagne 3 inches
s'est incliné site magnifique du tour là
on a eu un master piece de calvi pardon
à faire quoi d'amd cette dame 7 car il y
avait six des sept matches
ouais et ça fait 3 2 mais a il faudra
pas retourner dans cette ouverture à mon
avis non non non mauvaise partie
mauvaise partie au niveau de l'ouverture
mais max qui reprend l'avantagé qui
reprend le 3 2 est allé ce serait bien
de faire le premier break un seb et
prendre les deux points d'avance il
change ici aussi il retourne pas dans la
cambrousse ring qui part dans la c'est
moscou selon leurs envies de moscou et à
bosses colas les pièces est réparé
attention la sarine il a dû travailler
ça des heures et des heures
j'aime pas du tout je n'aime pas du tout
ça avec les noirs et je joue ça depuis
20 ans
enfin mais c'est ça me fait penser c'est
vrai ça fait penser à la blague des
inconnus c'est lundi cette boîte de nuit
elle est nulle
je vais l'accueillir gb tous les
week-ends depuis cinq ans cette arme de
moscou et je la trouve en réalité j'ai
l'impression que le prix des erreurs
pour les noirs est beaucoup plus cher
que pour les blancs que tu te fais bien
entrer dedans c'est à développer que tu
développes pas tes pièces et laisse le
roi au centre on va après mon maxime
s'est complètement son élément
donc là dessus c'est quand même plutôt
une bonne chose après c'est vrai par
beaucoup joué et a l'impression que les
blancs s'y font pas c'est maxime qui a
changé ou c'est l'autre c'est maxime
c'est maxime maximum parce que les deux
dernières étaient mauvaises pour lui
quand même moins dé cambridge il allait
c'était dur de moscou est le truc c'est
qu'il ya un pion de plus il ya ce roi au
centre il n'y a pas vraiment d'endroit
pour hockey et si on vous précis avec
les noirs ça tient bien mais la moindre
erreur c'est la sortie de piste alors
que côté blanc on peut faire une voire
deux imprécisions et on continue à avoir
une position où on peut retourner les
choses quoi alors que côté noir vraiment
une erreur c c'est c'est fini direct ou
l'alaska me garer les prend 1,5 et prend
1,5 et des processus
c'est quoi ce catastrophique c'est déjà
fini tu vois déjà fuit la catastrophique
de maxime je peux d'art te raconter une
petite anecdote il ya deux ans avant les
candidats à berlin j'étais sur la
terrasse chez moi et j'ai demandé à vlad
pourquoi dingli rennes joue la vente de
moscou avec les noirs contre contre les
slaves
sur quoi vlad m'a dit je ne sais pas non
plus ce qui m'a bien fait rire
d'ailleurs si tu te rappelles ils
avaient été complètement perdant contre
gries tchouk dink avec cette vente de
moscou l'avez raté mais mais il avait
raté un + 8 ou quelque chose comme ça
c'est un enfer à jouer avec les noirs
vraiment
à l'aude il l'a vu qu'il ya quelque
chose qui clochait l'appareil calcule tu
as a réussi un ouais ça marche dans les
deux sens annoncé kata à maxime avec les
dents c'est pas du tout ça la place et
après vue qui volontairement il ne joue
pas là grünfeld is handicap largement 1
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment complexe
c'est vraiment complexe à jouer et moi
pourquoi j'aime ça bah écoutes je joue
cette ouverture
parce que j'ai le même problème que que
notre ami maxime en fait c'est à dire
que je suis mal dans la cambridge spring
je suis mal dans la bo de vie nique et
c'est celle où fut le moins mal c'est la
vente de moscou parce que j'ai un peu
les mêmes qualités que maxime en
beaucoup moins fort mais du coup bah je
me retrouve souvent avec des parties
catastrophique comme ça qu'on est en
train de suivre
[Musique]
c'est dan de moins
airois faible c'est catastrophique saab
[Musique]
c'est une catastrophe
donc j'avais poussé c'est un câble sat y
avoir un roi h1 et f4 non ici pour les
blancs ouais ouais un peu tous des
frères on peut passer aussi via quatre
baies 3 il peut tout faire sauter la
préfère qu'il y ait des cinq peut-être
voilà j'aurai fait caler des cinq
équidés 5 agréable qu'elle des cinq pour
liquider au maximum à voir cette case f5
elle va vraiment falloir qu'ils
réagissent maxime il va vraiment falloir
une réaction côté français avec les
noirs parce que je n'aime pas voir ce
score c'est qui qui se dessine pas côté
français 1
ça mériterait vraiment d'avoir un ou
deux points d'avancé et ça se dessine
pas allez peut-être sarine qui rate il
réfléchit un peu trop peut-être là niall
ça peut laisser des chances y fait à 4 à
salah revient à 4-3 mais là là là on 5 +
1 c'est mort une chose dont trois plus
sa rivale gêné je pense qu'il n'ya pas
en péril farinia pas il peut en interne
mais très peu moi je penses tu étais pas
loin de 1000 dire il va pas en faire
dans gi oh ouais ça allait partir ça
allait partir
j'ai failli dire là il aurait insulté
mais non là pour le voir voilà il ya le
temps comme il peut réfléchir trois
minutes il a encore deux minutes
vraiment il prend son temps il accéléra
une minute je pense qu'il va envoyer un
caïd et 5 1 quand même ça paraît
tellement beau ce cavalier prise b5
prises des cinq caïds et 5
allez hop je pense cependant que sur roy
h1 il veut faire h5 af447 jettent car je
pense et ce à son idée ouais ça serait
sympa ça comme fin de partie matt qui
ferait plaisir il ajouté maxime
tellement fort ressources et un même
dans les parties qu'il a jouées troupe
mois là
il a trouvé des ressources incroyables
c'est sa force n'avait qu'une d'avant
moi y'a pas de soucis cinq bateaux
cravate a raté maxime qui se fait
écorcher avec les noirs chaque partie et
avec les blancs on va y dominent grave
sauf cette première partie où il a
complètement laissé filer le poisson on
nous demande qui avait gagné le speech
est junior bas c'était sarine
injustement qui s'était débarrassé de
sarah na en finale ans maxime va jouer
le blocus sur sur des six couleurs
opposées à cette époque c'est pas c'est
plutôt bien joué c'est très bien joué il
n'y a là aussi battu sara n'a le
week-end dernier je crois que c'était au
tournoi du cap d'agde n'ont ni à la
ligne hal qui dans cette joute nouvelle
génération qu'on peut appeler la next
gen
là c'est assez fort dans les rapides et
les médecins c'est c'est un des plus des
plus gênants derrière firoud déjà mais
ce que tu vas pas réussir à faire nul
quand même finalement là dedans voilà
attention attention attention il peut y
avoir des forteresses
on est tout proche qui a dépensé 4 ans
et 4 tours 5
autour d une part non mais que ce n'est
pas juste nul même genre c'est même pas
qu'on en est pas loin c'est que je suis
les changes une paire de tours assez nul
lorgner le four des fuites la tour en d6
finito quelle défense de maxime donc là
incroyable incroyable des chances à il
esquisse un petit sourire là la cam il
est content ça peut ça peut être ça peut
être
un point psychologique là pour le
français a géré ça nul parce que six
tirs l'adula et qui convertit dans la
prochaine il prend enfin ce break
d'avancé qu'on attend depuis depuis le
début la guerre est longtemps resté
vingt minutes un besoin alors je vais
dire ça il reste 25 minutes
il va rester il va rester quoi il va
rester une partie derrière il reste deux
parties quoi ouais mais restera deux
parties peut il peut viser plus de
c'était l'objectif peut en rester trois
mêmes suivant comment ça se passe à
brest c'est trop s'il a une troisième
avec les blancs ça peut être très
intéressant s'ils pouvaient aller
chercher un +3 ce serait exceptionnel
après on va pas on va pas mettre la
charrue avant les boeufs celle-là
l'annulait l'est pas encore fait
tarifs 4 ça m'a paru un peu bizarre m du
coup tu as plus de levier
ouais y'a des trucs là au roi est faible
il peut jouer mais sur le taux auquel a
signé tout de suite fait un tour en 1 h
4 tours désistement est là finito il va
essayer de pousser un peu mais ça va pas
aller très loin près il a intérêt à la
jouer toute façon pour faire dans les
dix ce qui est marrant c'est que si on
enlève les pions h et que on enlève le
fouloir eva c'est nul
donc c'est pour dire à quel point la
position
enfin c'est nul oui oui quel tour g 6e 6
oui même avec le pian g5 seigneuret là
c'est nul nul faut juste pas trop près
move c'est pas se rendre le h5
c'est là c'est le seul risque tout cas
énorme défense sainte maxime et sarine
qui la pousse pas juste que ça bon bien
sauvé max bien sauvé parce que c'est dur
avec les noirs ils à 50% avec les noirs
et c'est quand même du miracle
allez y retourne dans le 4 5 là-bas
aussi attendait là on est pas de secret
à mon avis va plus en changer un jour
avant les bulles est à mon avis à
leucate tu peux tu peux mettre une pièce
dessus il a fait un petit tour sur son
ouverture il est vite revenu au
classique
oui les boulettes ce sera autre chose il
revient à temps reprend à deux fois j'ai
cinq coups des deux cavaliers fiscales
et des 5
il a une très bonne position après karel
et prend qu on prend car elle et à sa
taille change signal qui change et qui
par chantal sallèles et nous lourds eux
aussi celle là cela les douloureuses
maxime il la connaît très très bien
c'est dur pour nice a cédé position où
il faut être
il faut s'appeler car yakine quoi il
faut défendre défendre une position qui
est vraiment pas excitante et j'ai
l'impression que ça lui convient pas
trop à cette ouverture
après quand tu es vraiment surclassé par
la préparation dans l'ouverture de ton
adversaire tu pas forcément d'options
ont donné autant avoir une position où
tellement bien et proche de l'égalité
tout cas notre maxime qui régale 1 ce
soir
hidden donne tout il a perdu une partie
entre guillemets contre le cours du jeu
le reste pour peut dire que 4 2 ce
serait quand même le score logique ici 4
2 3 1 3 et demi de normal je reviens la
première est qu'on est quand même un peu
compensé avec la dernière demi point et
qui aurait peut-être après après je suis
un peu chauvin aussi un de ses deux
seules des élections
tous reviennent ici comme ça me paraît
assez logique pour essayer d'échanger
les tours le plus rapidement possible
est-ce qu'on profite de cette tour en a
deux pour tenter un damas où est ce
qu'on joue tour un pour rejouer à
cologne où les deux sont possibles
suivant les deux sont possibles mais
accolade à est souvent plus importante
adam g 4 là c'est bien joué parce que si
tu échanges suivent apporter installé un
petit pion pions g5 et puis va
exactement c'est tour en est à 4 et tu
rentres en force
parce qu'il peut pas tenir la colonnade
il devait tourner vite tu manges leurs
dessins
tut introduit en a 7 puis une meinau
temps c6 et tu continue à progresser
pour une torrent à cet essai ci soit si
tu peux faire ça tu fais mal pour pour
te dire avec l'expérience des speechs à
cela on est dans un moment très très
important sable du match où on sent le
on sent maxime prendre le devant et ça
peut ça peut faire très très mal en ces
fins de cinq plus un début 3 + 1 j'ai
déjà vu des 4 5 0 s'enchaîner tu vois
c'est un moment charnière du match et
maxime qui peut il peut gagner ce match
là dans l'est dans les cinq partis à
venir il peut il peut il peut faire la
différence
or ce qui étonnant quand même c'est que
comme l'a dit mathieu sa reine
enfin maxime je vous le saia plus de 20
parties dans la base et l'un il jouait
encore en bis des cinq des centaines de
quoi lancer les normes et la prépa
tsarine elle est vraiment très limités
on te dit que tu joues le numéro deux
mondial en blitz sur un match de ce
pitch est essaye de préparer
je comprends pas je pense qu'il s'est
préparé un mais tu sais ici pas préparé
à travaux 15e couilles sait plus quoi
faire
tu t'es pas les 14 premiers coups de les
jouer à tempo et après sait plus quoi
faire
c'est papa oui c'est pas à se préparer
aussi c'est possible
c'est fou que c'est terrible
fermez là c'est pareil à cette position
ça va tuer de terreur pour lui ces
mauvais fou et collages ouverte pour les
blancs à noter que les noirs ont la
colonne ouverte mais cherchons des silva
cherchons des iaa 4 simplement 5 à 4
tours prend des 5 comprend si tu
reprends avec la tour au journal sis et
après il va aller attaquer le pion c'est
cet essai très très passifs non c'est
peut-être la meilleure chance après pour
les noirs ça ouais ouais c'est possible
du coup tu as plus plus une faiblesse
ans et 7 c'est quand même pas si mal et
brutale plein de talent qui ont décapité
comme très faible qui va sauter avec g5
et tour ces capteurs en d4
voilà c'est terrible alors à qui rentre
aux siens à non ça va pas du tout c'est
le fiasco et 3 minutes 30 d'avancé pour
maximin
en mai les 30 voix excuse moi tu te
prépares tu arrives pas au 20e coup avec
quatre buts de retard en vite c'est pas
possible
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'il est nul
ouais mais le mec est nul
oui mais voilà c'est jean roudière faut
dire les vraies choses quand il est
juste nul le reiki la de douane est
vraiment nulle quoi ça c'est ça le truc
tu peux pas dire avec mathieu en
commentaire là c'est là c'est très très
dur à jouer ça va aller à 4
on attend en même temps il a 40 ans
messieurs pas tout lui demander la vie
de famille et c'est la bonne nouvelle en
plus si maxime la gagne vite c'est qu'il
va peut-être y avoir une partie de +105
plus ça et ça on prend h is ok donc tour
à 7 cécile se fait fixée j'ai en train
de me dire tour à 7 sur ses seins qui à
tour à 5 non violence
magnifique j'étais content là bas
c'était une merveille sa victoire
tranquille on prend et le pion passé qui
fait mal
en effet roi le 2 faut pas laisser le
roi comme arrivant 17,1 non 08 là est le
problème c'est que tour à sept fous des
huit tours à huit
maintenant il ya trois sets alors
qu'avec laurent g8 y avait plus à oui
oui c'est vrai ça je vais montrer ça
donc c'est mal joué de la part de maxime
redonne un peu moore un peu facile
trèbes où ça fait plusieurs fois qu'ils
laissent traîner des positions comme ça
là bon il a quatre minutes de 3000
davance position très avantageuse mais
c'est vrai que ça peut se défendre
peut-être marée noire ouais bah tant il
ya plus qu une faiblesse c'est cette il
revient à 17 c nul tout de suite c'est
dommage sur deux quand même ouais 4 au 8
one ont mal joué là mal joué c'est
terrible alors le roi va rentrer en jeu
4 quand même il menace rien c'est pas
fou sur quatre comme ça c'est pas grand
chose
on commençait ont commencé à souffler un
peu à dire ça y est enfin break
il y avait des cinq ici
des cinq as peut-être au f5 c'est son
idée attention parce formaté ça va être
dangereux f5 suffit qu'ils bougent le
fou mais alger 6 maintenant ça va pas
cette fouet cette attaque becker après
sarine refait un peu la même erreur dans
toutes les parties c'est que je me
répète un maïs mais quand même
dramatiquement mal autant tu ne peux pas
te laisser avec 28 secondes maximum à
ivan ou l'arnaqué est quand même celle
là oui bien sûr qu'il est plus gros
favoris pour l'un à quai la pendule
c'est quand même un ces normes savoir un
pion quoi ça vaut un pion ou deux mais
bon là le problème c'est que les
couvrons pas être si compliqué que ça tu
fais g6 f5 tu bloques tout sur blanc ce
8 mai sur blanc est ce qu'il va faire
bref 5 f5 pour maxime la normale très
important j'ai cinq bien jouer h5 regard
le roi peut pas s'approcher il ya un mur
ouais surtout qu'il ya retrouvé huit
tours g8 la wii en béton g8 et le contre
jeux annoncés mais tu sais quoi c'est
les même plus facile à jouer pour les
noirs maintenant et oui tu peux même
s'il a bien joué par contre foule pour
avoir tour huit fois f2 et attaquer ici
ouais ça contrôle g3 et de trois super
cinq coups des quatre tours fc avec mon
servat maxime qui a rétabli la normalité
est ce qu'il y avait peut-être la tour f
5 mai aniane la joue pour gagner je
pense et oui qui allait avoir un père
pète direct direct par maxime va faire
rage et un connaissant loustics occase
raté la côte est côté français la case
raté
l'énorme occaz et sallèles peut elle
peut faire mal dans le cas où il se
remet en difficulté hyper avec les noirs
tu a légalisé sous marine où il a changé
dé ces quatre candidats d'accepter j'ai
jamais vu maxime jour un grand vide à
m'accepter je crois
attention les yeux on a deux joueurs qui
souffrent énormément avec les noix sont
souvent foutu après leur coup donc là on
a quand même quelque chose
voilà quelque chose qui va pas dans la
prépare en tout cas je vais te dire ça
s'est mal passé dans la cambridge ça
s'est très mal placées dans dans la
moscou ça peut pas être pire même sans
connaître octo rives être pire et puis
en plus là dessus il ya souvent des
finales donc en finale je suis quand
même plutôt confiant pour maxime c'est
souvent des finales ultra technique et
je pense pas que ça arrive et la
technique d'un dunk ramener coût d'un
joueur russe s'est pas encore un crack
en finale même si pour son âge je le
trouve quand même assez complet mais
c'est pas c'est pas un crack en plus on
s'est vraiment pas vraiment quel âge il
a pas ce que c'est c'est des choses qui
sont beaucoup vu dans le sport de haut
niveau les dates de naissance truquée
c'est quelque chose qui s'est beaucoup
fait et qui se fait encore aujourd'hui
dans des contrées éloignées des nôtres
si vous vraiment trop bien au final dans
ces cas la fin enfin faire un test
est ce que c'est possible d'ailleurs de
connaître l'âge de quelqu'un par un par
une prise de sang par un test adn
c'est par le tas un seul test pour le
savoir je crois le monde croit que c'est
par les eaux parce que le carbone 14 à
mon avis non alors les eaux et là au
seul sait les eaux
bah ouais c'est le chat le confirme
radios deezer orange et on va les
prélever un petit morceau d'os ce coquin
et par la moustache par la moustache
aw est un mec a une moustache de daron
c'est sûr qu'il a fait sans règle kg une
moustache de ouf et les gens et qu'ils
essaient d'avoir les moustaches pareil
en 50 ans de carrière il arrête toi
comme bon alors salade position très
très plate 1 maxime a égalisé
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est une bonne
nouvelle et c'est donc du rotor est ce
qu'un d'armes à 5 damage 5 serait pas
dans le site de notre maxime ça pourquoi
pas une petite et puis dans la 3 aussi
poussé suisse tous ici j'aurai un
cavalier e 5 mais bon il doit avoir vu
quelque chose qu'a eu 5 fu des 5 sur un
an là il va bouger la dame
on s'attend un petit fouace damas cinq
bien dans son style x 3 salut art à mios
fois trois voies ses copines c'est une
belle épine x 3 annoncés bien joué
foix iii qui empêche à 7 tours de
trouver une bonne case
alors qu'est ce qui va nous faire le
petit sarine
est ce que fout better a foulé d'oeil à
damas cinq pardon aux dames cette cg
j'ai eu un coup de j'ai un goût de flip
sur flu et de madame c'est d'amener
idéalement placé liberia casse pour la
tournée 8
c'est très très très bien la maxime qui
a enfin trouvé son ouverture avec avec
les noirs 6 il peut continuer dessus et
papa ce faire mettre en danger ça va
être un tournant de ma tient ses gros
soulagement
il reste combien temps il reste onze
minutes 5
ouais donc il y aura une partie encore
derrière sébastien la liaison avec les
blancs c'est parfait c'est exactement ce
qu'on veut elle ferait prendre ce plus
de la dameuse est si je pense vraiment
c'est dommage qu'il ait pas eu tous
rêvent des 8 es fou 8 ici qui aurait pu
être un coup il va faire flouer quatre
fous des cinq noms il va partir vers
l'avant
un briquet habillement dans l'autre sens
du tout trente trois ans qu'elle est
bien qui manque dans le sens inverse
dans un sens classique et qui abîme dans
l'autre sens c'est que moi je suis
toujours pas avoir la moustache de goût
cash à 12 ans je n'arrive pas dix ans le
même âge enfin quand je faisais les
championnats juniors est un petit
poussin de dix ans d'écart c'est
incroyable j'étais petit en plus gamma
gt flagrant du coup il fait quand il
faut prendre ces quatre pouces et 5
pouces et six pouces et 6 ol il a envie
de jouer qu'on se fout c4 en fait qui
est très très faible c'est assez bien
joué
ce qu'on voit très bien que les pions g2
f34 b3 sont tous sur couleurs blanches
et des pions le 6/7 comme tu as mis en
rouge la bloque le rayonnement de ce fou
donc assez bien jouer ce coup fourré 6
y'a plus qu'à échanger les fous de cases
noires mais se fonde 1 3 il est bien
aussi
eh bien allez tous rêvent dé 8 la
tranquille ban moi je le sens bien nous
claquer un tour prend 2,4 pouces et 6 il
est pas important on va jouer sur 15
mois l'objectif c'est les cases noires
on les voit à l'écrasement règles sont
belles elles sont belles donc la tour
des huit a les joues tour de vis pour y
réfléchir qu'elle décède peut-être
peut-être qu'à et 17 et 17 jouer il veut
forcer une décision
ba est ce qu'il veut en fait le sait ce
qu'il veut quand il veut arriver avec un
cavalier qu on me fout là le voir il est
gros comme une maison
ah et puis là les petits pièges qui
prend tout reprend 1,5 sous bush pousser
ça tourne dans le bon sens là mais
l'accueil prend 17 c'est le bon coup
c'est ça qui est marrant c'est que vous
mangez le cavalier pâle ou pour pas
créer un déséquilibre il ce qu'il va le
trouver le bouquet reprend 17,6 et des
coups pas simplement ça compliqué
mon invité quand même tenté par kelly
prend ses 6 pi sarine il va jouer quel
français si ce nom un qu'elle prend 2,7
mais heureux époux b6 sais tu sais quoi
il avait pas un fou prend g7 c'est quoi
ça les balles des quatre dames prend 17
ouais mais tu te fais moi tu te fais
marcher dessus sur quasiment après b5
je pensais tout en danger ouais c'était
une tactique et rock loukili ans et 5
c'était le cherche même s'il restait
peut-être même un piège volontaire de
maxime fou bessin pas mal tout bessone
pour prendre possession de la colas et
où vous c'est vous serrez cette régie
des eaux à l'est c'est au nom il l'a
raté ouais mais attends ils menacent
tout reprendre et six pouces et 5 n'a
pas me pousser encore mais bon il a pas
vu mais il peut tomber atteindrait tours
l2 il ya quoi
il y est plus sûr tous rêvent de waimes
et tous rêvent 2 quand même les pièces
les pièces d'argent tu as vu à la cave
j'ai pas si de la vue je veux dire que
la vie moi je regardais pas la cas
moment il a vu bon mais c'est à dire que
sarine l'a vu aussi mais d'un autre côté
ça ça se goupille bien on l'avait
annoncé les cases noires les cases
noires il ya ce coup à la tête
mais tu sais quoi peut-être que tour
c'est si c'est encore même plus fort il
a fait tour c'est de l'auto rêve de
annoncé pas plus fort lors sa grille
tout de suite c'est vrai le banc après
la stratégie commenté gagnant tout
autour c'est 8 hyper bien j'ai encore ça
peut être un tournant psychologique faut
pas la rater parce qu en ayant raté une
tactique comme ça sur as tu la gagnes
derrière il râle beaucoup les roms
beaucoup tu peux vrai que plusieurs
partis pour être la plus simple qu'un
quasiment passé c'est fou quoi il le
domine bien et là il n'ya pas assez
poussé 1 et 1,5 et le fou à plus de
ouais ouais ouais tiens là c'est encore
masterpiece tous ses relais va le jouer
au foot tient la corde
c'est c'est gros mieux à faire que vient
faire dame est fou c'est un gamin c'est
quoi de balkh et surtout f4 joué trois
fous j'ai trois dans le sens assez beau
non c'est pas possible on l'a marabouté
parce que paimpont une vieille dame 1 il
y avait foule f 4 x 3 poule g 3 c'est
pas possible à bas prix restent bien
il permet d'allier permis je pense est
très bon et opposition c'est bien de
toute façon il y aura une autre partie
derrière cinq minutes là ça peut pas ça
peut pas durer allez là y'a tout reprend
b 6 pouces et 5 cette fois ci attend en
v 6 n a pas la rater non c'est pas
possible et peut pas rater ça voilà ça
s'est joué loti n'en pouvait plus la
papy ça arrive
ah bah oui pape sy sarr il est tard la
volée au lit la balle est folle à finir
proprement fou j'ai trois c'est parfait
leroy et réseauter série dames c'est
cinq points c'est quoi là ça va ça va
gagner ça à faire + 2 on sent on sent
qu'il a passée l'accélérateur maxime
excédent à ce moment du match qui peut
qui peut vraiment faire la diff
il peut y mettre incluse 3 qui serait
connue c'est cet ici peut-être d'un
match 4 matches 4 j'aime bien tu rentres
tu rentres sur les cases pour céder aux
six ans tu me diras avec l'ajout quoi
quand même c'est beau la cage où aller
c'est celle là allez celle d'avant il a
laissé échapper bons rails et u12 u14 là
tu vas devoir changer là que des
poubelles ils devraient avoir 4 0 un
échange qui chargerait il va se prendre
la 2 cavaliers prépa maquis et cavaler
alors attention maxime jo que ça depuis
4 5 ans et jules avantage fiscal assez
intéressant de choix et les dates de
dames de jeu par maxime ici on espère un
quart et les 17 rivage
régis kg 3 ok qu'est léger 3 pour
essayer de sortir et j'ai six bons ses
positions ils sont un peu mieux pour les
blancs toujours avec avantage l'espace
il va lui faire un petit poucet
qu'attache 3 pour jouer contre ce fou
ces huit fois nous n'a que peu pas à
sortir il le laisse sortir
wallace pas dramatique comme le disque
avec le four angers 7 c'est quand même
un petit peu mieux pour les blancs
simplement s'il n'y a pas ces trucs avec
dams et sept fous des six donc les bleus
reuters organisé rivage ou trois bons il
a d'abord je crois ça va arriver ça va
tomber
ça va les changer en f3 et 1707 boss
c'était c'était sûr c'était sur les gens
sont venus suivent note maxime quand
même aller alors qu'est ce qui nous fait
ça fait chier
peter hill yam izard je ne comprends le
fou ces huit hanoune a prédit stream
c'est vrai ce cas tous les scripts à
deux trois gars qui est écrit brasse et
j'ai enfin compris pourquoi on l'a fait
le poids saran le truc encore plus drôle
du coup cavale et h5 et cultivent eux
échanger des pièces c'est plutôt
intelligent pour les noirs dans cette
structure
attention au final son traîneau est ce
que mais bon pourquoi pas qu'elle à
chaque âge 3.931 tranquillement j'ai
trois dames trangé 3 et le problème
c'est qu'on a la possession de cette
diagonale l'abbé 8 h 2 et qui
normalement ont valu d'avancé 7 et un
four des six pour les noirs donc c'est
clairement une amélioration pour le
blanc et ya pouvoir met en place son
plan à quatre ou afca pour des 1
et puis pourquoi pas jusqu'à tâche
changes pour affaiblir
insupportable avec les noirs pendant
beaucoup n'avaient portable et dès que
jouent ces cinq en fait les blancs on
prend à ses cinq et on va essayer de
tout est changé pour jouer la majorité
donc là on a des schémas très très connu
pour les noir et blanc
après ça reste solide pour les noirs il
resterait solide très solide parce qu'on
voit que la structure sis à vii c'est 6
17 ans pêche à ce fou blanc d'avoir un
rayonnement
d'après la même des plans à la fois f1
j'ai quatre fous g2b quatre à quatre
baies 5 à ce fou qui rebry bras cassé un
bon coup là comme souvent quatre packs
adjamé roxy ouais mais bon pas le temps
tu fais mal on tue famille elle tente la
jouer là ce qui est important c'est pas
sur les changes et les fous de cases
noires c'est un peu l'idée ne jamais
prendre en d5 aussi évidemment on est 5
6 ans tu es tout de suite moins bien les
noirs s'alarmer la structure en place
vous j'ai trois kébé si on veut avoir du
fou d36 joue à cinq ira du a4 est vrai
souvent là je commence à craquer je
pense à faire à cinq là j'en peux plus à
l'air il le fait et le fait obligés à 5
à 4 mais là ça commence à m'énerver
rafou et fluide food et si c'était une
option après attention ouais donc
pourquoi pas free to day 6 quai des 5
j'ai essayé de faire un deuil b3 b6
stars dont bénéficie ce peut-être ici
proposent les changes les échanges et
serait pas grave ici mais je pense que
tu les gardes quand même pour le moment
d'acheter ses doigts cavaillé f4 ou
fois-çi ces points f4 je ne me trouve
pas super précis avec les blancs quand
même nom pour le moment ça va
adam est ce assez bien j'aurai pas ce
que fait niall f3 l'on peut jouer
ouais ok f3 pas idiot mais bon je trouve
que kenya joue vraiment bien cette
position
alors comment max va nous jouer ça il va
essayer de jouer j'ai 4 ans je pense
ouais alors si on met un pion et ça doit
être se veut comme assez égal on va dire
que c'est plus agréable à jouer avec les
blancs à très long terme mais
objectivement c'est égal je dirais ça il
peut il changer je suis soirée dans là
c'est vraiment là c'est complètement
égal et va juger quatre comme si sûr
qu'ils me jauger car sûrement ici là
pour avoir le pion achète en target
s'est peut-être doubler sur la colonne h
à risque le h6 peu près ce que j'allais
dire ok mais là c'est bien 3 e tour a
choisi de faire coulisser alors été noir
comment comment il va essayer de trouver
du jeu elle dame essayer d'affaiblir le
bessin que le ciel taper sur b2 comme
kick ass est faible car il y avait six
existe pas terrible orange et 3g 3g à
partir à mon avis immédiatement mais je
tête retour d'armand arrive autour des 5
tu sais quoi
ouais je joue f4 après le jouet f4 je
commence à vraiment prendre l'espace
bayard efficace à tempo il peut pas
prendre peut pas prendre sinon ils vont
bien a hissé il a très bien joué pendant
longtemps et là il s'est un peu trompé
mais il reste encore quand même dans le
règne de quelque chose de nul et un
probablement 4ème et oui tout à fait
mais bon voilà en fait les blancs
commencent à fixer ses pions sur cases
blanches du coup ses pions qui s'avère
être une force pour les noirs vont se
retrouver des faiblesses tout reprendre
et 5e simple comprend des 5e 5 bien
mettre le carignan et fluide j'imagine
ouais mais là tu te fais fixé tu prend
2,6 toujours au f4 plus aux voitures
entre 20,5
oui je passe un live car si faux permis
là il va t'en as et cinq à foix iv
pardon
ah mais il peut peut-être faire tour des
6 es tu peux pas prendre l'accueil prend
peut-être c5 un coup il se doit
pas facile à avoir ces 5 c'est un joueur
qui jouait très bien ses positions avec
les noirs joueurs français c'était
robert fontaine fois qu'il les joue
encore très bien d'ailleurs robert il
était bon pour défendre ces trucs là je
suis pas mal de parties de lui oui oui
jouer str classe solide et défendez
pendant longtemps alors il ya menace la
menace m51 maintenant avec les
dominations la colonne eux donc c'est
quand même bien jouer ce tour de même
très bien joué je dirais à tour deux
tours à jeu qui va partir et j'ai cinq
cavaliers 6 3 doit alors si on va
attaquer ce pion à auch où est-ce qu'on
joue f5 moi j'aime bien et puisse en
prendre possession de la colonne f
et puis en fait avoir cette majorité
parce que ce qu'on joue quand même sur
ce 4 compte trois belles dames
ma vie va partir pour tanger 8,3 et
fuite mais attention aux pions à chis
que sinon ça fait pas sens en fait ces
derniers coup d'être vu un f6 ou quoi
attention à ces c'est bien mieux pour
les blancs et puis c'est dur à jouer
avec les noirs et peu de coups le
cavalier comme beaucoup de cases
cette faiblesse en lashes cette
possibilité de jouer g5 de joie f5 et
puis s'étend sur la colonne des qui font
rien au final
qu'est ce qui se passe surtout rage de
ckoi son idées naïves c5 et contre je
dois l'avouer il veut filer h ici la
raison veut filer achi c'est très bien
joué
maxime qui gagne un petit tempo sur la
tour avant de partir foulbé 3ème à
l'entourage de courage de ses seins qui
veut faire qu il y aura six pions
pranger 5
enfin peut-être du g5 tout de suite pour
gagner tempo et avoir tout rachète un
c'est pas mal
bref de ses 5 g 5 puis on prend qui
comprend qu'ils aient bouge amérique
eric caravaca 3,4 attendu un beau
salaire plutôt bien pour les blancs
comme avec la poésie qu'il ait changé
peut-être perdre le tour
c'est la première fois que n'y allez pas
si mal que ça autant avec les noirs
c'est déjà une amélioration par rapport
à ces espagnols au moins ils en capacité
de de jouer vite aller sa part là-dedans
et g5 tout de suite ça joue
j'en prends pions prend cavaliers h à sa
tête et achètent roi roger 4,48 et ici
tout rage deux tours j'ai vite il à
l'espace mais c'est solide
je continue à penser qu'avec un jeu
parfait c'est nul 1 ici oui oui tout à
fait
malgré la pression exercée par par
maxime après sarine moi je le trouve
trop faim je suis désolé je le trouve
trop lent pas assez concentré lorsque
c'est pas à lui de jouer je trouve ça
comme si calculé que sur que sur son
temps alors après c'est des joueurs de
haut niveau mais j'ai l'impression qu'il
n'est pas assez assez impliqué après at
il les capacités d'être concentrés
pendant trois heures et demi d'affilée
c'est une autre question aussi un mais
manque un poil de concentration
peut-être sur le temps adverse pour
jouer un tout petit peu plus vite tout
reprend g8
qu'est ce que c'est que ça à cet égard
ouais maxime qui ce qui se mêle à qui se
met la tête devant les lunettes ovales
et jean piat énorme gaffe de maxime est
maintenant maxime qui va jouer là nul
c'était la défaite serait terrible bah
ça relancerait complètement sarine quand
on pouvait lui mettre la tête sous l'eau
et puis s'en vont après le mec a très
peu de temps ça va être très très dur et
gagner
ouais ça va être dur à gagner mais sa
relance sa relance le match
menacé quatre c4 ladilafé b6 pour
défendre
maxime qui échangent pense qu'il a eu
raison un de liquider le cavalier way
qu'il y ait trop dangereux b5 je trouve
que c'est bien joué en no way il va la
tenir cette position il va la tenir
la tour eiffe de saint-claude sûrement
moi j'adore à kiev 5 5 f 4 persos way
est prête à ceux qui ont acquis et que
retarder c'est égal à 3 kg à ses ventes
c'est ryan anciennement refill le pion
aux quais attention il n'y a plus de
temps la moncelle à temps mais c'est
sarine césarine qui craque c'est sarine
qui est en train de craquer il avait il
à tour assistera cette tour prend fc 3 3
way s'est retournée sarine caf a fait
très très mal pour le re pour le joueur
indien celle-là et maxime qui sort à +3
moncet ben écoute match de rêve pour le
moment de la part du français
il reste plus de parties de plus en plus
dans cette cadence non ok oui c'est la
bonne salah elle fait très très mal
bon après c'est comme vous savez il l'a
volé en effet je voulais tellement files
s'étaient pas fait voler il a juste
oublié le score devrait être ça devrait
être 5 0 avec les blancs je pense que
quatre points d'écart serait vraiment la
logique logique mais mon rapport on est
peut-être un peu un peu chauvin nos
maris là il a complètement dominé les
cinq parties avec les blancs ok celle-là
on peut la corde et il doit peut-être
faire nul et sinon ces quatre ennemis de
mes ennemis je pense quatre ennemis 0 et
demi et avec les noirs il a une houle a
très bien joué et 3 où il était très
molle ça fait ça au final donc ça fait
cinq et demi et larry l'a6 trouve c'est
plutôt un tout petit peu bien payé pour
lui on va dire 104 nuls dans celle là ça
aurait été normal mais si on est plutôt
bien payée du coup mais mais bon c'est
bien celle-là il à aix avec cette fin de
set
oui il serait en très bonne position
pour la suite des matchs
bah disons que là s'il réussit appuyant
3 + 5 et sa meilleure cadence et faire
et refaire plus de +3 bah il prend il
arrive au plus 5 + 6 et c'est là la zone
dont je te parlais plus 5 + 6 avant les
bullet ça ça a suffit pour être
tranquille et normalement pas se faire
de frayeurs ouais c'est ce qu'on vise
donc exactement ce qu'on vise
on est très très bien parti dans ce
match et maxime qui pour le moment tient
son rang alors si tu veux faire une
petite pause scène n'hésite pas si tu
veux pas faire de pause n'hésite pas non
plus comme tu sors ça va ça va tout
tombait je te laisse répondent au tchad
je leur mette un peu de la pub histoire
l'histoire de leur faire mal
regardez juste le score
de mes joueurs bordelais ont pris 4 0 à
monaco parfaite ça c'est mal de petits 4
hervé pavy
[Musique]
ça reprend encore ça reprend bientôt un
10 minutes non sans minus 6 je croit
généralement six minutes avant moi les
mecs sont précis demain c'est qu'un
jeune qui joue demain c'est 400 ou
commentée par maxime est ce que ça va
être marrant ça va être top tu suivras
un petit peu améliorée après oui il est
plus il fera une quarante ans à peine et
après ça enchaînera on en verra on te
fait la première fête c'est la première
partie de ton de ton envol
et oui ça avant le décollage et on va
chercher les 2900 avant le décollage de
mazet on vient avec maxime retrait de 18
heures jusqu'à 1h du mat
ah oui c'est là seraient eux maxime il
relevé pull maxime qui est bien maxime
qui a joué avec l'autre caméra qui a le
micro professionnel et très très bien où
maxime bordeaux bordeaux se joue en cfa
4e division
ils ont même perdu contre marseille dans
cette année omeyyade à marseille annonce
a permis à domicile heureusement on
allait voir avec mathieu le beau match
bordeaux-marseille l'arrière et à partir
de la 70e minute bordeaux était
tellement contente pas perdre ils ont
fait 0-0
il est plus une place dans le camp d'été
pour garder leur corps regardez le
record de 40 ans bondissent bordeaux a
pris un super ailier de reims
et oui ils ont pris audine c'est ça la
codi wood 1 6 et 1 rue c'est à dire
voilà français alors c'est peut-être
parce qu'en russe en fête ou dean ses
fins à six a dit ça veut dire 1 à 10 da
dilva très serré ça parle de lorus aux
doors ou daoudov
d'autres encore autre chose si c'est
bien longtemps qui a pas une grande
équipe abordera 2009
gourcuff avec gourcuff c'était pas mal
voilà donc sabbath 2009-2010 avant
c'était zidane etc
voilà c'était une vraie belle équipe 1 à
bordeaux ce qui fait ce qui est
important c'est le rugby il ya que ça
qui compte à bordeaux avec les béglais
les vrais bordeaux baylet mais
malheureusement avec le confinement ils
ont perdu leur titre de lairière ya pas
été attribués alors qu'y gagner tous
leurs matches ouais mais cette année
c'est un peu plus difficile pour le
moment mais une belle équipe mais
surtout de bordeaux s'est lancée qu'au
foot le public est catastrophique et en
libye c'est le meilleur public de france
quasiment rempli à 100% depuis depuis
nombreuses années comme la rochelle
vraiment le sud ouest c'est important le
rugby ah bah oui tout le monde de
l'ovalie 1
mais c'est beau sport le rugby comme à
toulouse d'ailleurs toulouse le foot et
il s'en cogne tellement important le
rugby c'est vraiment un beau spa des
belles valeurs des puits les joueurs ils
sont vraiment sympas les côtoyer pas
comme le foot
oui c'est un peu oui très clairement
très clairement ni bordeaux ne vaut pas
toulouse ça c'est sûr aussi mais
bordeaux a bordeaux ils ont marre ils
ont eu rios 5ème qui est pour moi le
meilleur entraîneur du top 14
bien sûr toulouse c'est là c'est la
bible toulouse c'est monstrueux mais tu
as vu le match d'hier soir ou pas du
tout l'équipe de france hier contre
l'irlande
quand tu vois antoine dupont en neuf
franchement ca
pour moi c'est le meilleur 9 du monde
aujourd'hui il est il a tout en fait ce
gars vraiment une belle équipe là dupont
ntamack et on est beaux joueurs partout
là non
guitoune ils ont fuit coup ils ont ils
ont du beau monde de partout une super
troisième ligne il nous manque juste un
peu tu vois la première ligne un peu
qu'on avait à l'époque avec servat
tantes à l'honneur la tv la meilleure
ligue du monde et sert vat servette
était vraiment incroyable
ibanez bah oui en fait c'est marrant
pêche un peu en première ligne
aujourd'hui chez les piliers mais bon
après la formation elle devrait être
très très bonne donc je pense qu'il
devrait à nouveau pilier on a vakatawa
russie vous avec vous oubliez trop fort
c'est n'importe quoi
le mec et tchité tam et quant à du pur
vakatawa que ça va chanter sur les ailes
avec avec fickou ou non en deuxième
centre est et était dit thomas allèles
ça fait très très mal encore que teddy
thomas moi je suis pas fan mais bon
après c'est quand même un énorme joueur
enfin ça fait plaisir de retrouver une
belle équipe de france de rugby puisque
ça faisait longtemps
bah franchement la coupe du monde a été
sympa c'était un saut c'est ce
qu'annonce cette erreur carton rouge
mais il a réussi en demi finale il avait
fait un beau match sur une belle équipe
quand même s'il était arrivé dans les
conditions catastrophiques
c'était prévisible de cette génération
ils se sont ils se sont retrouvés à ils
se sont ils se sont retrouvés à lors de
la coupe du monde ray est donc là 2023
ils peuvent être très costaud on va
gagner en 2023 ouais bon après il faut
voir ce que dans le sud ils jouent bien
autre chose
well et les box et les boks physiquement
c'est comme un scroll ouais mais tu
verras on verra on verra je nous trouve
je nous trouve vraiment bon je vous
trouve vraiment beau râler renault échec
avant meubles un peu pendant la pause 1
ça arrive ne sign qui est toujours pas
revenu sarine qui est dans le coin c'est
marrant je le vois sur l'autre calmes du
coup la cape par des
hier et les justes dans le coin de sa
chance en fait il s'est mis au coin tout
seul c'est marrant il est vraiment dans
le coin et puis six autos puni quoi il
est pas grand quand même un de taille il
répondre dans le coin c'est terrible il
y fait les quatre cents pas dans le coin
de ses effets des petits tours sur
lui-même dans le coin de sa chambre
j'ai jamais vu ça il doit être déçu
quand même hein ça fait mal
psychologiquement
allez y revient s'asseoir ou alors il se
pose la question de vlad pourquoi tu
joues non mais cette question est
vraiment mythique
pourquoi tu je m'en vais pas de ce truc
là les revenues sign é là il a plus trop
le sourire là d'habitude on le voit
joyeux faut quand même qu'ils gardent le
sourire alors le 3 + 1 c'est une heure
du coup une heure de trop qui est ce que
tu es bien sûr la presle 1h30 de 5 + 5
maxime est plus fort en 5 + 1 parce que
je suis sûr de quoi est ce que tu es
bien sûr que maxime soit plus fort en 5
+18 manque quatre ou cinq heures de jeu
de plus quand même là je n'étais pas sûr
tu vois ça va bien voulu qu'ils
continuent encore une ou deux heures
ouais tiens cc c'est exactement ça
c'était sa hâte a un goût d'inachevé et
non recyclées s'était pas bien sur quoi
c'est pénible
saran le défaut quoi de celui des échecs
de 16 ans ouais le génie des échecs de
36 ans 2 c'est ça et ils sont quand même
bien en dessous de fil rouge à cette
armée side c'est pas du tout en génie
faut arrêter ça joue bien une travail
10h30 heure par jour
c'est tout je suis d'accord avec toi
c'est inférieur
c'est inférieur à fuir aux jo ça se voit
le placement des pièces jointes ou quoi
c'est non c'est vraiment très inférieurs
affiche un bond et karkwa nouvelle
génération ça calcul très très vite
ces calculs très très vite et ça a plein
de très bons réflexes et ça va jouer
vite mais bon après je suis pas sûr que
quand il va se taper les russes à gogo
dans les gros tournois qu'ils fassent
très très mal
c'est tellement difficile à dépasser ce
stade là quand tu parles tu arrives à
j'avais vu comment s'appelle will be
c'était la mégastar les échecs et et
2007 sans faille avait pas 2007 sarine
l'entité déjà 2007 à 15 16 ans et puis
finalement ça rien donné finalement ça
voilà invité encore hyper jeune je crois
qu'il arrive à 23
mais bon on sait qu'il va pas y aller je
frappe à l'effort il n'arrivera pas il à
la chaîne
il a lâché 1 d'ailleurs c'est possible
qu'ils aient lâché 1
il a lâché je crois qu'il est hissé
mille îles et eefje des étudiants
jacques ndjoli il est très très jeune
encore ainsi de l'avis des filets il a
ainsi la valeur normale
ouais il a lâché 21 ans est un peu plus
quoi précédé choix de vie sains
oui il est hyper talentueux mais c'est
vraiment que du calcul par bateau comme
ça renko sarine là on voit quand même la
différence entre un sarine et un mec du
top longue allant vraiment sur les
parties je les trouvais moyens même pas
vraiment très moyen quoi j'en aurai maxi
il passera maxime après ou pas on peut
lui demander éventuellement serait
vraiment intéressant d'avoir son avis
que je trouve vraiment qu'avec les noirs
il ya 2
très très peu de fil à retordre avec les
blancs bon maxime a fait un peu et par
c'est bizarre enfilant un pion en baisse
6 comme ça en enfilant une dame et
pourtant il est comme un score correct
il est vraiment plus fort qu'il n'y a
pas de n'y a pas de division a pas de ya
pas de comparaison possible
[Musique]
le blog à lyon de ce badge ou qui je me
rappelle déjà plus jeune vainqueur d'un
autre match sa lettre aux parents
peuvent en fait je laisse une bataille
maxime tu es annoncé sa tête de série
était de série numéro 3 à 4 un temps en
misant ils ont ils ont tout changé
et en fait c'est ce que j'étais en temps
je vais regarder pour les voeux mais bon
il est vrai c'est ça les ponts et les
one c'est ce que j'explique à aba qui en
fait j'ai tellement appris le tableau
il devait avoir un appariement pourri où
il devait jouer apparemment au premier
tour et artemiev au deuxième et
finalement et finalement est ce que je
veux dire des poneys thowar orient ces
deux monstres et là il joue comme un
joueur qui gagne beaucoup au couvent
renfort même si tu joues parau sarine
c'est quand même beaucoup moins fort que
les peaux les rues ouais mais les 23 qui
l'a pas un gros classement sur czech
comme quoi je c pas grave tu essaies tu
as much as comme aulas il repart il
repart avec des c4 qui est très très
bien marché ouais il repart il a il a
trouvé sa variante ouais ça ça nous
plaît ça ça nous plaît ce qui devrait il
demande à l'autre de faire le jeu et
pour lui c'est assez simple écoute sont
assez simples à une position solide
alors que les autres peuples et
cambridge etc
il était vraiment dans le dur tout de
suite alors je t'annonce que si maxime
kassala est la prochaine le match est
gagné
oui bien sûr là sur les deux prochaines
parties maxime il peut enfoncer le clou
s'il gagne ces deux là alors l'autre et
ça change il a dû travailler cette ligne
un petit peu pendant la pause
ce qui a aidé car à j'allais dire est ce
qu'il ya des quatre pouces et si c'est
une option mais alors ça l'était le coût
des ventes est vrai celle là c'est
interdit là c'est un service que ça
casse sa structure avec le pur ans et
cissé en a six pendant la question cette
pollution c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait de
la dame en réalité pas souvent fait elle
vient en deux sets
c'est pour ça que tu as l'air fou à
trois dames set c'était super alors
est-ce qu'on réédite alors là un peu
moins golf r b to b 5
alors là c'est plus artistique dans qui
menace ou prend f1 et surtout prend
bessette il a tout repensé un fou prend
enfin tout faire coulisser la demande
des 8 par exemple naître une toile ans
évite donc toujours un ton france et un
arbre en c1 dames pays vitrine web
quelque chose comme ça paraît assez
solide
en fait c'est quand même l'ouverture
voilà cette structure depuis ont
complètement symétrique
c'est juste un jeu de pièces qui fait la
différence
donc si les noirs arrivent alors là il
ya foule ces six quand même si on peut
échanger se fout c'est une très bonne
nouvelle
ah oui puisque on a tous les pions sur
blanc le voit ffck
donc ça c'est pour changer la structure
et jouer cavalier 17 cavaliers c5 qui
l'a pas ratée fougue et cette fois ci
dessous des stars et fourbe et 7 à temps
mais c'est pas si sûr fou mais cette
tourbe et huit fois à six tours à tomber
lui tout arrêtent pas foulé si ce
fardeau qu'est x 6 damas ici la foulée 5
as-tu fils tu récupères interview du
père a de bons gènes pas trop mais c'est
quand même bien la paire de flou et trop
fort mais bon ça joue la bonne nouvelle
c'est que sarine accélère pas là rythme
aux sciences début de cadence parce que
la trouver cette fois ci c'est quand
même quelque chose que tu as envie de
jouer assez rapidement alors peut-être
que ces spirales la linke pour bien voir
ça lui plaît pas ouais mais oui oui
sûrement mais si relâche encore une
minute tu vois que c'est ce qui lui a
coûté aussi au final 1 dans la première
heure
ça fait tout à fait c'est pour ça qu'on
pense que cette cadence est vraiment
idéal pour maxime c'est à dire chaque
minute de réflexion sera bien plus
dramatique qu'en 5 + 1
là il est en train de lui faire très
très mal aniane il à lui mettre la tête
sous les 3000 à huy miracle qui pourrait
ressortir de ce match de 1990 ou quelque
chose comme ça et maxime qui peut passer
les 3100 dans ce match fait d'un mât 4
alors tu vois le coût est peut-être bon
mais le fait d'avoir grillé une minutes
et 5 secondes
pour moi c'est une erreur c'est ça que
j'aime beaucoup c'est dans l'esprit
grünfeld tu files le pur mais après tu
as les cases noires c'était intéressant
alors ce qu'elle voulait faire fou prend
des calculs on prend des cats et jouer
contre les pions pendant attend surtout
près ce que l'autre peut jouer tourcoing
avec l'idée de menacer la dame et double
dames 3,6 surmonter sur la salle
couleurs les deux ans les rebonds c'est
plutôt une bonne position pour les
blancs comme dams et cède donc la dame
prend la 6
il n'ya pas tour à 8,1 le fouet 3 il va
jouer cinq de tête pour l'essayer de jeu
d'éliminer ce fou de cases noires pour
des huit ok donc il est moins bien mais
mes bons avantages autant quand même de
40 secondes
alors il est vraiment - via rail pour la
peine c'est un vrai mot pions parce que
ses pions père de fou c'est du rhin et
attendait et le truc qui me chiffonne un
peu aussi c'est que la balle est de
nouveau dans son camp avec les noirs il
a de nouveau souffert dans l'ouverture
alors comment tu progresses avec les
blancs seb
il faut essayer de taille d'attaquer ses
pions b1 donc pour b tour b1 et essayer
de mettre une pression donc l'idée c'est
des gîtes arriver et changer le pion
sait où le petit roi contre le pion b
puis après de jouer avec le plus en plus
et d'échanger des pièces donc la maxime
fait bien son blocus en champion v8 de
pied pas un fou 5 qui rôde un fou
décisif où pranger set tu vas genre de
truc ça pose problème d'abbas est j'ai
peur que mes six tombes ici
il ya toujours cinq enfants deux
variantes c'est son idée oui mais il
faut deux je crois à la fin si tu
prenais pays s'ils s'y prenait à deux je
pense et il a attaqué le fou auquel
croit mais là ça sent mauvais mais
regard 24 secondes pour sarine et max un
mail à son blocus et la sa position
christien voilà il va jouer les coûts
rapidement ouais je pense que en tenant
compte de la pendule n'est même pas si
moins bien que ça tu vois ouais faut
cette fois m6 peut-être à wade de joie
sarine qui essaye d'accélérer
il accélère un peu tard à les changer
toutes les tours est fou à 7
ça doit faire nul ça à l'écart et en c5
et monstres qui contrôle les deux pions
g6 ou g7 fouet cette dame à cinq gamins
pas mal de pas mal de choix et 17
why not il revient on sait que le tandem
dame cavaliers meilleur que dan fouts en
général adjoint fo prend il va peut-être
jouer pions prend fo prend exception
française évidence vous gagnez la case
aux cavaliers nuancé 5 quand même ça
reste intéressant là 18 secondes contre
32 on va voir ce que ce que ça donne
lorsque les deux deux hommes doivent
jouer rapidement
ces trois hommes bouge respire et a4
force
qu'est-ce que ça arrive va réussir à
organiser un danger c'était pas trop de
façon de progresser dans sur des lots
ces trois républiques la dame ces deux
on sait pas trop ce qu'il veut elle
arrive pas avancer le sarouel peut-être
qui replace son fou autrement un
peut-être se fout ce four b3 là qui le
gêne il était mieux place en f3 j'ai
l'impression ils bougent leur en f1 ce
genre de partie qui jettent un pont
c'est quasiment du 50-50 herman ans
parce que les blancs si ça lasse assez
bien joué pour cette 6 e dan
jour alors qu'elle joue comme ça on est
cool avec le plus pernes voilà c'est nul
c'est complètement nul
ce que lebron posée au des connexions
déconnexions pour sarine oh c'est
terrible mais avoue connaissant maxime
il va proposer nul ouais proposition nul
a accepté par par maxime mais fair-play
un maxime c'était pas loin alors
peut-être sous le niveau de la connexion
alors qu'est ce qu'ils nous préparent
lot 10 euros par dossier ou pas ils
veulent assassiner il va continuer à
jouer tes 3 3 oui on réfléchit détroit 3
trop incroyable être aussi faire plus
incompréhensible à il peut peut-être se
faire signaler un sur trois comme pour
comportement trop sportif ouais c'est
limite
c'est très limite c'est limite humiliant
pour son adversaire c'est très limité
ans qui vient de faire maxime à
hydrogène
il se régalait cette idée alors une
grosse line théorique est ok voilà voilà
c'est ça c'est ce que j'appelle une
prépa une grosse prépa des deux joueurs
qui connaissent exactement ce qu'il faut
faire et ça fait nul à la fin la voilà
ça ça je m'attendais plutôt à ça de la
part sarine en 5 + 1 il fait ça en trois
puissants alors qu'il n'a pas vraiment
révisé puisqu'il faisait les 400 pas
dans le coin de sa chambre
non je sais pas à quel moment il l'a à
quel moment il a eu la prépare en fait
ça c'est une partie de cornavin j'en
suis sûr concret s'ils ne savaient pas
fini comme ça mais c'était comme ça en
début de partie mais là je dis qu'il
connaît plus l'aïe a pas le choix je
veux juste dire si tu prends 20 le truc
qui fait peur c'est un mot si ce voyage
ils sont froids de semioli cellule forcé
admettons dame bien juste montrer leurs
intérêts les âges qui se croient je suis
d'alger huit tours angers 8 carélie
afsset en gros c'est ça qui fait peur
exact pour faire simple kate programme
aussi c'est là c'est un coup de dames
quelque part sur la huitième donc on le
8 tu peux pas payer des six jeunes
l'hélice habilité d'une force l'ériger
5k relief s'atténue mais il retrouve pas
qu'est ce qui se passe là j'ai tout fait
une peau pour pas se rappeler
il va réfléchir là qu'est ce qui fait la
cave irréfléchie injustement jette là je
réfléchirai faudra clairement ils se
rappellent pas à ce serait beau là
qu'ils se rappellent pas et qu'il la
perde
arrêtons là il peut y que je m jusqu'à
20 second il y aura su mener 10 pour
trouver quand même
il se rappelle pas d'un v8
tu peux même le trouver sur l'échiquier
comme mata pas trop chaud ça se voit
qu'ils se rappellent pas là ouais mais
tu sais tu peux te mettre à calculer
truc de type skype rang 1 dames 6 damas
six l'année là dessus a cavalé h6 double
échec et tout ça mais tu peux commencer
à te attend mêler les pinceaux ça passe
vite en une minute maxime qui joue tempo
bien évidemment et là il ya que dame b 8
seul coup que 2008 messieurs
bon ça c'est une théorique pas si cons
soit tu trouves soit tu trouves pas il
se rappelle pas et tu sais parfois il ya
une erreur psychologique qui peut être
fait quand tu te rappelles pas d'une itt
s'est énervé du fait patent rappelé au
lieu de calculer
chéticamp hondelatte ressasser le fais
je me rappelle pas assez relou au lieu
de de faire le boulot j'imagine c'était
déjà arrivé
bien sûr bien sûr et je te reconcentrer
sur la position tu essayes juste d'être
en mode mémoire mémoire mémoire et tu te
rappelles jamais et c'est vrai qu'il a
presque envie de jouer la gagne sur
donne des huit américains lalalalalala
une kelkoo catastrophique aliot 5 à
vendre
c'est ouf ouf de l'apartheid mais tu
vois ça ça c'est pas un joueur qui joue
le titre mondial là c'est pas possible
c'est trop faible non là c'est faible
trop faible quoi c'est une catastrophe
et car il est 17 c'est fini je comprends
pas comment des joueurs comme ça on 3040
surface comme pas possible quoi ça
triche maso qui va nous faire un road to
3200 donnez-moi s'arrêtant maintenant je
comprends pas où on va être aussi faible
au lieu de me filer les monstres
arménien et compagnie d'années - sarine
quoi bon alors maxime faut qu'il soit
pris si un pas fou prend alors qu'à la
mauvaise blague en maths et sur h3 et
cavaliers f3 matt aut 6-1 celle là
suivez les jolies d'ailleurs j'ai jamais
vu des comme ça
ouais les travaux est mignon c'est quoi
ces g3 du coup j'ai trois fils le fou en
plus tu peux aussi t'amuser à m
peut-être ah oui il faut faire rire
bouzid pas faire un genre dame ses huit
dames c'est trop il ya qui avait l'air
froid double échec et mat
red bull va tu dans ta gueule si j'ai
fait mal voilà ici va pas se tromper un
ballon rond f1 je suis tellement simple
ouais c'est jouer il n'y a pas d'erreur
en fait il n'y a pas d'erreur
bah oui papy sarine fatigué très très
très très mauvaise impression sur ce
match pour moi vraiment pas au niveau
elle à +4 et sa chambre dans le chatt
duchess comme un pas dans pas dans le
nôtre mais non c'est l'école the bee
pini alice pleutre c'est que ça commence
à être n'importe quoi c'est ça commence
à se pâmer les américains qui vont de
nouveau être en sueur qui vont nouveau
appelé m'a plu appelés demain matin en
me disant qu'elle vous foutez quoi dans
le chat ne peut rien 3 l'un l'a atteint
un très mauvais match c'est pas digne
d'un joueur qui joue ouais c'est
étonnant quand même parce qu'ils
savaient qu'ils allaient rentrer dedans
ils se rappellent pas il retrouve pas
sur l'échiquier quoi ces doubles
double faute est là c'est bien f 4 il
aura pas fou prend des 4 yadan des huit
dames des cinq dames prend des cadres à
ces deux groupes qui ont moins là et ça
va être converties alors attention ce
qu'il essaye de faire c'est pas si bête
hein il veut faire touré fils est bloqué
a battu pousse ses pions qui pousse les
gens tu peux pas y a pas de l'opus
numéro en 2004 tu pousses f4 gens qui
sous la houlette de pas abandonné il ya
un levier qui fera mal et tu pourras pas
tout protéger
il va faire un f4 g4 g5 à un moment
donné un double levier évidemment s'il
n'y a pas une journée où il n'ya pas le
pion fc nul mais là il ya beaucoup trop
à régler pour l'adversaire
après je trouve que c'est pas un manque
de fair play de la jouer ici un de la
part de sarlat c'est normal c'est tout à
fait normal de jouer ici
tout à fait d'accord c'est normal c'est
gagnant pour les blancs mais il faut
encore le faire il peut y avoir
voilà deux exemples l'adav environ 2,6
d'azf 5 il a joué 5
le roi va être bloquée sur la huitième
et on en parle plus cette année c'est
bourré 5
c'est la beauté d échec 6-6
l'investisseur est allé c'est bien ça
commença à monté +4
allez on arrive on arrive dans la zone
qu'on veut qu'on veut avoir pour éviter
toute turbulence s'aime on creuse
là il a pris un coup sur la tête le
sarine un gros coup sur la tête ça même
s'il est peut-être plus forts en bulles
est il variera pas ça me fait tout à
fait penser au match de tennis ou
incinérés nadal à roland c'est un peu
chaud c'est un peu chaud c'est un peu
chaud puis un moment donné tu compares
sarine à six heures ça va pas non mais
ouais c'était pour un match récent
kouame
moi je t'aurais dit thierry champion
comme sergi bruguera des terribles ans
mais là il fait la gueule ça arrive je
te remets la gamme pour que tu vois là
il est bientôt le gérant même plus il va
descendre petit à petit arrêt non là il
fait la gueule à ça se voit que ça se
voit que ça va puis rentre dans la
finale il n'en peut plus dans la vie là
ça va pas du tout aller après ça qui
peut aussi en vouloir à l'organisation
qui ne fait un match qui ne dure que
3h30 4h il doit se dire sur un match de
dix huit 20h11 j'avais ma chance on
était plus sûr quand même ça qui doit
être déçu un de jouer aussi peu de temps
face à maxime peut le comprendre
c'est compliqué pour ça rime dans cette
finale aller tranquillement pour pour
maxime tu mêleront recettes et tu
tournes quoi cette fille elle est mieux
pour les blancs mais bon là je pense
qu'il a aucun souci du plan ce qui leur
a aucun souci un type 2 peut mieux pour
les blues pour davantage d espace avoir
foulé cette ressource et huit tours des
mais voilà il arrive petit à petit
égaliser non mais sarens est un genre
tactique c'est clairement leur tactique
c'est pas du tout ses positions par
après il défend bien c'est vrai qu'il a
une belle des belles capacités de
ressources
ça c'est vrai d'ailleurs quand je vois
les jouets en beach j'avais détruit et
puis malet trouver une ressource
c'est incroyable ah ils sont forts pour
trouver les ressources après le truc
c'est qu'on contre dmv elles ont des
nouvelles voilà les ressources sa sont
plus ouverts ouais vous contrarie la 3d
ressources avoir passé plus samuel qui a
été non chaque scène je pense pas
qu'elle ait mal joué je pense juste
qu'il est tellement d'avancé autant que
pour lui quand je discutais avec maximy
pour lui le temps c'est très très
important donc ils préfèrent jouer des
rues de chercher un gars gardez la
pression au jour des petits coups comme
ce qu'il a fait et puis après évidemment
ça craque en phase quant à une seconde
et laborieux
mais voilà il peut y avoir des accidents
comme la première partie du match mais
voilà on aime beaucoup sa maxime qui
joue l'hyperactivité avec se plonger de
se fouler cette qui rentrent en jeu
alors évidemment loti saute dessus parce
que c'est son domaine
donc il peut aller récupérer un pion et
il peut être à virer attention mais
quand même position active pour maximum
mais maintenant il veut rentrer ans et
leur très clairement de quel français
cinq choix un choix étonnant comme de
maxime au final crier ce pion après
maxime nous il nous le disait un
vendredi soir ça peut être son défaut
parfois quand il fait un peu l'écart ou
quoi il peut avoir une petite saute de
concentration
ouais ouais mais c'est normal et arrêtez
de vouloir mettre la tête sous l'eau la
grèce et elle prévoit exposition la foux
qu on vous prend ses capés et de pioncer
va sauter ça peut faire deux pions
mauresque ça serait quand même dommage
de laisser sarina revenir un peu dans ce
match avant d'être arrivé à la zone des
plus 6 + 7 lacs et des deux fous des
cinq cavaliers à 5 à 5 c'est mal joué
cavalier à 5 puis d'aider leurs yeux 4
ici c'est incroyable qu'à 5 lucas loyers
bloqués est obligé de jouer ça du coup
il peut prendre mais maintenant ils
m'annoncent nuls parce que les deux fous
sont trop forts pour une faute de sarine
auquel il a été beaucoup plus simple à
jouer au hockey du coup là c'est un pur
- évidemment il peut pas échanger les
fous ou sinon cfoot couleurs opposées
nuls et une composition très active pour
les noirs avec le roi qui l'a menacé
d'arriver et il va pas avoir du tout de
mal à faire du dans cette position très
très mal joué encore ce cas là il ya
cinq parties sarine quel 3 pouces est
ici souffle b3 pour déchets à pousser
les pions 26 les pions ne peuvent jamais
avant c'est fou b 3e 5 3-6 7-5 pas mal
de choix non ça va la tenir à notre sens
assez simple comme dans l'est
comment s'appelle dans les marshall où
les blancs aura plus en plus en finale
avec contre les de fouet les deux fous
sont beaucoup trop actif et encore plus
de chance pour les bleus
c'était là c'est compliqué mais bon
c'est un plan plus donc maxime va devoir
être précis donc là il faut vraiment
qu'ils activent sont rois parce que ça
soit aussi s'asseoir et des saps a peut
être poussé cette phobie 6 faut prendre
trois ouais ouais
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il veut bea fous
ces cinq essais nul tout de suite ouais
moi j'aime moins quand même bien j'aime
mon à saint béat tu penses l'afutt
couleurs opposées ici peut ne pas être
nul va est toujours compliqué avec ce
puits on achète qui est un peu faible
et puis ce doublé des pions aussi en
fait ce doublé des pions roi c'est
lorsqu'il me faire un blocage avis on va
c63 b5 c'est pas mal ça peut te 3 7 6 1
je préférerais qu'il va lâcher comme ça
il va échanger au dernier moment en fait
voilà là c'est mieux parce que c'est
plus intéressant mais l'autre veut car à
lyon 5-5 c'était bien fou des deux mains
non une et deux vous venez de maxime
jouer à 5 trop vite pourquoi le plan
rail en fait il n'avait pas de pions de
l'autre côté ils pouvaient rien faire
qui lui a offert un freeroll les fous
choix foot pro 3 et la sobeca ces
troubles et 4 qui fait très très adroit
il aura camaïeu 5-1 ça pue ouais ouais
ouais mais ya pas de coup là en fait il
n'y a pas de course que si la fougue et
4 c'est fini aussi mal joué maximas un
filet relâcher notre passion f500
compliqué ce sont ces bien jouer il faut
qu'ils gardent bassim shati la f4 ils
bloquent une réforme de cavale ça c'est
typique maxima n'en fout prend à 3
mètres il va chercher à 3 ouais c'est
bien joué sur kadhafi s'il a de nouveau
foulé cette il fallait tenir
il a réfléchi au bon moment là c'est
très bien je de sapins way est en train
de la sauver il n'ya pas foot royaux et
roy prend 1,5
fou des quatre jours et qu'ils arrivent
à jouer à 5-4 dans ce cas que trois
secondes à la pendule un très très
compliquée à jouer trois secondes ouais
pillay a de moins en moins de pionsat
doit faire nul de manière mécanique
maintenant mais photographe encore 5 3
secondes
le 4 méga tube quoi qui a aidé 5
j'imagine ce que 3000 va prendre du
fouet la foux prend et roy prend à
shahukhel assez nul sans aucun problème
ouais t'as même pas besoin du roi non
pour faire mieux puisque quand il fait
j'ai ici je vais vous prendre qui
comprend 13
même pas besoin de points allez on lui
en revue avec les blancs est lautier
report il se rappelle pas de dembé 8 il
ne porte le tenir de tendres alors
maxime dame ne vois là on l'y attendait
floue elle 5 ha ok donc la ligne
intéressante
linde hobbit 5e le doigt très très bien
connaître mais ça va aller pour maxime
un verre sur une nouvelle fois il va
faire quoi faire cailler g3 qu'avait
lieu 5.6 manon 12 / d'armes prohibées
d'actifs ou g5 j avoue g5 la dame prend
b2 je vais prendre trois ça bizarre très
belle jouer ça j'ai trop parce que
maintenant j'ai trois foulées de rock
well cavaliers h4 c'est très très
plaisant mais tu vois pour pour moi ça
ce sont des erreurs
qui sont liées à la pression qu'eux mais
maxime sur le match et ont su laisser en
fait ils essayent de tenter ce que dame
prend il ya aucune chance de gain et je
prends il ya un déséquilibre
donc ils espèrent pouvoir s'en sortir
mais là cavalier h4 petit rock ça va
vraiment faire très très mal cette
position
non ça va ça va bien se passer après fou
des deux faits qui avaient des catalans
fut g6 il faut toujours vérifier les
cavaliers pros eu 6 1 ouais ça marche
pas ça doit pas marcher mais ça étonnant
qu'ils aient des cats et ou non mais je
pense qu'il veut bouger 6h 4h et 6h 4h 1
quand même mais h 4 quand ils jouent h 5
pourquoi pas mais tête il veut claquer
en russie ça tu sais quoi
on brade pas ce risque trois des huit ya
rien normalement tu le fais quand tu as
déjà roquettes à tour ici quand même au
moins voilà minimum de l'écrivain lui
seul peut pas très drôle non là tu
places c'est aux blancs de jouer
peut-être ce sera intéressant et encore
donc le mec et 1030 ce 30 secondes à
jouer sous les 6 c'est où 37 secondes
ray salalah quelque chose de ses looks
mais c'est pas le premier match où je le
vois faire ça ce que je fous j'ai six
comme c'est le seul cours n'est pas de
ne pas trente six coups juste pour
répondre aux gars qu'ils discutent dans
le chat à tequila david en fait le truc
c'est que tu as peut-être sur 50 matchs
de ce pitch est dans l'année tu en as
peut-être d'aller on va dire 30 qui sont
pliés après 1h30 de match et il ya
encore deux heures donc si on rigole du
format c'est parce que on aime bien les
matches longs mais on aime bien les
matches donc on s'est serré s'il a déjà
6 0 6 1 6 2 tu veux pas les deux
derniers sets là c'est un petit peu la
même chose c'est qu'en fait on serait
pas contre que ce soit très long comme
ça l'est et qu'il ya des supers matches
qui sont serrés mais un format 7 est
plus adapté parce que du coup bah quand
c'est serré ça joue longtemps et quand
c'est pas serré la personne gagne
rapidement quoi c'est un peu l'un se ce
qu'ils voient dans tous les sports
d'ailleurs c'est bien sûr leur voix
l'idée de maxime de caïds et 4 de jouer
avec b 4 pour son cavalier
au lieu d'être 1 h 4 soit en d4 pour
participer à la fête
catastrophe pour les noirs je pense
qu'il est obligé de vous impliquer que 5
mais tu aimes pas du tout normalement
brian b5 b5 bombay 5 c5 v6 ou la la la
la la la la
le carnage annoncé un carnage trembler 6
tours b un tat accra et scipion franck
et b5 annoncé fini ça pour en avoir joué
une quantité d'aidé dans des spas ouais
c'est ça l'esprit scandinave là mais
c'est complètement fini ça c'est une
candidate qui a très mal tourné mais je
comprends pas comment tu fais pas d'âme
propose aussi incroyable ça c'est
incroyable de la part de vagues de jeu
qui avait 3
il ya les respectes plus sur
l'adversaire il joue juste vite oui je
suis concentré parce que bercy s'était
on parlait plus un mal fou à chaque il y
aurait peut-être un petit peu petites
sautes de concentration l'appareil s'est
endormi
il s'est endormi bon après la mecque à
28 secondes mais bon c'est ça qui est
dommage et b6 a tué la position et en
plus en plus sur le live en a vu perdre
des quantités de parti comme ça j'en ai
perdu mais bon ok il refait cavaliers ou
car à travers les liens qu'il a car elle
y prend il faut un truc c'est que des
sacrifices de pièces l'arrêt l'étoile f4
et à quelles épreuves prof de tickets
mais aussi avec la dame qu'arrive enfin
je sais pas voilà fouet 4 way à la
mairesse b6 quand même salon sur f5 il
veut qu'elle prend ses 5 vous prend et
des cartes non oui là je b6 la gp si sûr
il n'a pas l'air a raté l'occasion
d'ouvrir les positions il va revenir en
détail que lecavalier
ouais ouais il va être mieux il va être
mieux l'auteur pas saisi sa chance que
tours projet troillard du fou et 5 à 4
tiens voilà ça tiens ta cette pièce
c'est incroyable et en plus il peut y
avoir des tours à 8,38 parfois enfin
deux variantes fiscale a pris quatre
c'est pas bête hein c'est pas mal ou à
ces quatre là où là il va il va se faire
mater sur regarde c'est cadre d'un
programme de deux tours avis matt nom
d'un proche des 3 qui avait pensé 5
mais qu'il faut prendre ces cinq échecs
mince voilà mais ses quatre tours d118
pour des absences de tours à huit
wells avait mis des ans meilleur ouais
voilà ces quatre d'écarter car qu'est-ce
que c'est quoi c'est parra mais il veut
dame baisse je comprends plus rien la
main qui ne sent pas une grande partie
il prend ses cinq hymnes asmat
maintenant à viadène prendre quatre
points sur échec fouras trois fous
procès cinq peut-être assez jolis seins
il l'a pas ratée l'automne à g et tours
à huit tours d1
il n'ya pas tours à huit tours d1 et ses
trois balles 6 il a tenté d'obliger de
presque sur bande des trois équipes rice
trois matches elle est sympa cette
partie nos jours des uns ou dam des
trois c'est pareil annoncé tour à tour à
3 les très mauvaises parties de temps
ouais ça aller catastrophique 1 et a
raté quatre cinq gars on sait là l
orissa l'hôte à 5 secondes qui va
essayer de l'embrouillé ouais mais carey
lieu de tout reprend j'ai bien vu avec
arrêt à 4 car il prend les trois
terribles cette partie n'était pas
concentré sur cette la maxime
il est passé à côté c'est dommage parce
que le match était clos quoi ouais
terrible enfin difficile vraie balle et
jouer avec x 6 et tu vois là on voit
vraiment le bon après il a raté des
trucs mais tactiquement il voit à la fin
ça va très vite que ouais il claque ça
dort il trouve les raisonnements tu
pourras 3 et claque bim bam boum
ouais c'est dommage
c'est dommage qu'il ait pas si l'epa qui
n'est pas terminée après il a tellement
d' avance sur son adversaire il est
tellement plus fort que ça va mais faut
pas laisser un truc bien tourner quoi le
qu'il peut te faire une bonne partie
revenir au moins deux tu sait jamais
ouais moi j'aime pas avant le avant le
bullet je veux pas qu'il soit plus de +3
je voudrais ben non il reste quand même
temps il reste du temps il reste il
reste 28 minutes c'est beaucoup et voilà
le pour la peine les cadences sont plus
équilibrée où chaque contrairement à la
phase qualificative où le bullet était
beaucoup plus important que tout le
reste là c'est qu'ils viendraient xhaka
dense et équilibré à 8,9 partie alors là
les doigts ont une bonne position
une bonne position équilibrée mais sans
s'en soucie attention à cette casse b5
quand même étonnant 5
elle est tellement sortie du match
maxime attention ces petits se tient au
relâchement façon il le dit c'est
toujours par par flux relévé parfois
tout rentre parfois ça va moins bien
donc à 5 à 4 on n'aime pas trop ça a
donné la casse b5 vraiment pour rien
puis surtout le public at il sert pas à
grand chose donc la dame b 5 ou paraître
vraiment une bonne option
ça va ça va être assez un coup naturel
dmb 520 russie juice athènes pour arte
mégafusion bessin bah ouais tu joues tu
joues une partie comme ça contre
artemiev tu vois plus le jour en effet
le 4 4 c'est mal joué
4 ça fait vite on est ton cavaliers
forte que d'erreurs que des erreurs de
l'autre mais là j'ai l'impression que
les deux je sais pas ce qui leur arrive
mais ils sont mis à mal jouer en même
temps l'an invoqué maxime l'a fait une
mauvaise partie vraiment le tas comme un
niveau assez élevé mais l'aude c'est
comme assez faible même la particule à
gagner des red deer est cent fois
on a quand même eu 4 c'est un très
mauvais coup mais là il y avait
peut-être un truc avec dam des huit noms
pour vous gagnez g3 je sais pas j'ai
vraiment l'impression que ça qui a eu
une baisse de régime la whey après c'est
long trois heures de jeu là bientôt on a
quoi on est allé on à 2h30 des jarrets
donc c'est normal de moins en moins bien
voir mais quand même tu voyais quand
même des coups même quand tu es fatigué
et des coupes tu fais pas quand même le
k3 là pour la peine 1,4 c'est vraiment
bizarre non la ja et qui est pas dans la
case des six assez bien joué pour la
peine ouais c'est bien joué donc maxime
peut jouer cavalier besset tous
cavaliers b3 pourrait changer un peu les
tours 28 ans b 3 non mambé 3 il peut se
retrouver à esthétiquement beau mais ne
servir à rien why am et ça commence à
contrôler la case des six qui a et b 3
c'est plus perdu contre je maxime
évidemment les fans de contre eux je n
aime pas la passivité il va avoir du tam
c5 qui va rentrer alors qu'eads et 6 ici
paraît fort c'est faux évidemment garder
une paire de tours que cette tour des
huit soit facile donc pareil la
réflexion de 20 secondes pour choquer
des six c'est beaucoup trop
voilà il est très très mal autant de
nouveau avec le même scénario que
d'habitude il prend énormément de temps
et je vois cavaliers des sites échange
les tours c'est nul tout de suite ça ça
n'arrive pas à comprendre ce que c'est
parce que c'est un joueur qui est
uniquement tactique est qui qui trouvent
tous ces coûts via le calcul ou ces
quelques années la raison de ces de ses
réflexions là qui n'en termine plut sais
pas je ne sais pas les c6 et s'il va
nous faire là exposé active est tombée 8
des cinq baies quatre caisses et 5 kms
est peut-être pas ce service est mêlé
c'est un regret arrive un f6 pour
essayer de vivre milliards f 4 tours des
4 ok maintenant c'est bien j'étais
étonné sur le coup par trois les 4 4 4
me paraissait ah bah non il émane la mc2
nouveau wii est mal là il est mal il est
très mal attention ne pas en perdre deux
d'affilée quand même important de pas la
perdre parce qu'on est encore une partie
moyenne de sarine donc deux parties
maurienne et par les deux parties c'est
quand même pas thierry est présent ici
c'est bizarre comme coup puisque sa
paire le socle mais ça c'est bizarre
c'est bizarre qu'est ce qu'il a décidé
de comprendre et de voir un truc avec
cavaliers f5 peut-être menacera carré
lieu cet homme et la tour peut bouger
quoi thomas roth ou dames c'est cette
même ya plein de choix mary jane absents
fait qu'ils jouent ça ring il joue
vraiment que tactique
moi je mexicain voilà max il doit
reprendre il n'y a pas le choix se
comprend des six la dame prend g5 et et
tu vas te faire mater il est rappelé en
quelques tours prend des six d'un projet
cinq tours 17
et peut-être une chance mais wii fit wii
le bon laquelle sa rentrée dans le jeu
de l'autre
pas sûr je sais pas s'il jouera ça c'est
ce qu'il a joué les tours 17 mg 6 à y
rentrer là dedans je pouvais prendre en
abscisse taxis hybrides herald
layada me 8 3 à 7 tours h4 qui menacent
maths elle aussi joue que pour ça que
c'est terrible qu'est ce qui nous fait
maxime là il met du suspense alors qu'il
doit pas en mettre ouais mais là il
n'est plus le plus faux cul sur sa
chaise un objet là ça va pas aller y
défend encore attendent un match c'est
3f cet onj et 4 il joue bien à l'autre
la hâte en robe point f 6-3 6-4 par
petit poisson dans l'eau là à hénon
irois 8 ya puis on prend et g8
eh ben on va voir un beau match on va
voir un beau match parce que maxime
s'est relâché ouais il m'a du suspense
ça sens à 100 et il fallait dans sa
chaise là est ressaisi
votre cible attend il n'a pas encore
perdu celle là il n'a pas encore perdu
il nous sort une grosse défense allez
les barbelés
alors les 5 secondes pour l'autre ouais
incroyable
après c'est ce serait mérité aussi pour
maxime il n'a pas voulu jouer à la
déconnexion il avoue jouer fair play et
ça lui retombe sur le coin de la gueule
c'est mérité de la torah je suis allée
la déconnexion attend quand j'ai pris 6
cette année c'est de faire un blocus
mais voilà plus de bloquer sa trame ici
me remets toi sur ta chaise la folie les
îles et reculer la halle body language
va pas du tout il en a marre est hs là
n'est pas dedans il joue g3 alors qui le
domine sur quatre complètement dans life
et n'importe quoi à maxime
on a un tilt messieurs nous avons un
tilt on le connaît ça ça c'est très dur
les tilt est là et il est là il est
fatigué mange une pomme
là il faut vraiment pas la personne là
elle a une âme il en a marre là il en a
marre ces matches son long après un pour
les joueurs aussi
ouais le trentenaire un bien unique roja
et des crocs à les regards regarde
comment il est focus est en cela il est
une perf au cul s'il a regardé il il a
relevé la tête et tous là ça va pas mais
ça vient de quoi attend ça commence et
où cette histoire il y avait plus de 10
candidats vont là où bat cent fois quoi
ah oui la halle b 6 il a tout il pour
faire + 5 et du coup il remet l'autre
dans le match à quoi mène après ces
quatre ça gagne mais il a fait n'importe
quoi l'autre fait deux points alors
qu'il doit faire 0 ils devraient ils
devraient être au moins à +4 là au bas
mot elle devait être à plus 5 avant la
partie d'abord c'était écrit le passé le
match était fini
et là il a plus de honte il tend donc il
peut très bien perdre seul
maxima ne va pas du tout toujours je me
dis language va pas rien voilà rien ne
va et il reste combien de temps dans la
cadence qui me rassure pas c'est qu'il
reste 20 minutes il va pas pouvoir
creuser un bel écart avant les bullet et
on va avoir des bulles est mon seb de
tous les dangers
ouais ouais on va voir du monde 1800
personnes
on va dépasser les 2000 mg tracks c max
max il veut que le match soit serré 2000
personnes c'est bien mais après si c'est
pour si c'est pour perdre mais mauvaise
position là on a une très mauvaise
position pour elle trois mois et
structures simples à la ja pas du tout
bonjour ici nke que s'enchaînent sa
hanche ça commence à bien jouer côté
indien il a pris la confiance il joue
mieux maintenant mais la maxime en fait
joue quelque chose qui ne jouent pas
l'habitude donc l'autre bombe à l'autre
etc alors bon joueur d'échec c'est
normal quoi c'est près d'oran bien
maintenant c'est terrible quoi cette
passivité tourbe est un fou prend ses
cinq étaient beaucoup trop moins bien il
le jouera jamais maxime c'est trop de
catastrophe ou prendre ses cinq tours
ben vraiment la seule chance pour
essayer de garder un peu des
complications mais le problème c'est
comme tu viens de jouer tour 1 pour le
moral c'est dur et là il est en train de
se caresser les cheveux c'est dur est
tombé un mac c'est chaud tourbe et un
rajout ouais je n'arrive pas à
comprendre à quel moment cette cette
baisse de tension est arrivé
cette fatigue des trois heures de jeu
torbey a bien joué lès tours bien ça
joue c'est pâques atteint encore pas
quand même la paire de fouet c'est les
structures comme dans les carreaux
cannes là ça va c'est pas toi t'es pas
cap est un coquin lacazette 4-1 bien sûr
bien sûr c'est juste que voilà il est
moins bien autant on est dans un schéma
de jeu qu'il est qu'il n'a jamais eu
depuis le début du match et tout le
temps une ou deux buts de plus donc là
il ya une position il va devoir défendre
mais c'est aussi la grande force de
maxime on a vu que sarine quand il
devait faire le jeu
eh bien nous sortir des coups très
surprenant là c'est un tremplin
on est peut-être à une partie tournant
du match où on a un match de folie qui
est très serré alors qu'ils devraient
pas l'être et sahélienne cette partie où
max gagne cette partie du coup ça lui
redonne un boulot steve haguy le match
facile ouais si maxime reprend un bout
c'est qu'il se remet à jouer comme comme
il a joué pendant les fêtes c'est sa
fille tu le sens les jockeys froid g3 il
sait pas quoi faire et enfin celle des
primes allaient des 4 et 6 des caps est
très fort pour les noix on ouvre dame c5
bien joué aussi pour faire des quatre
fous des deux des quatre arrêts forcés 4
et là c'est très compliqué les cases
noires le voit
et quand il revenir encore un ace à se
tenir on était moins bien tellement bien
des quatre là vraiment c'est naturel des
quatre places et quatre coups des trois
et on essaye de balle et oui c'est ce
qu'eric et en c5 c'est juste mieux
coiffés en rade à faire alors il
réfléchit des quatre jouer quand même
heureusement maïs que maxime peut tenter
un b 4 c 5 1 ont donné peut-être
peut-être pour et ses vices et le pion
bessette et le fourbe et 4 aussi en c5
peugeot est fou hausse est peut-être b6
oil & gas 4 ipad les quatre attention à
b4 la paix car tu comprends vous prend
on fera un papy 4 c'est quand même à des
quatre poules pense à relancer
complètement la partie ou des trois ici
je suis surpris j'espère qu'on pourra la
voir après je pense qu'il passera mais
après après le match mais au bail qui
doit se retourner dans sa chaise
parce que évidemment il reconnaît pas
max qu'elle un gros coup de moins bien
alors h4d 3 bien joué c'est foot peut
avoir je le fous détroit aussi maxime
qui a fait de même c'est un tempo et qui
prend le pion est sûre
[Musique]
mais il reprend simplement il reprend
ils repartent atika ma foi si séoul à la
wii wii ont la fougue des trois attaques
poway bien joué et la fois jamais quoi
carbure au lala lala lala retourne mois
tout roule pour aucun abandon aux quatre
abandons
ouais attendant adam trois tours 8
dames trois tours 8 c'est terminé
incroyable autant dans le doute il va
parler tout seul maxime qui joue grâce
au talent et à tout le talent qui joue
là chez maty sarr est moralement il a
disparu alors j'attends les fonds est
encore là et d'aïn la chaîne tour y 3 g
7 h 5 sûrement très fort incroyable
c'est là on voit la différence quand
même ouais c'est beau ça madame b 8
matches extraordinaires
bon allez devoir le faire à chaque album
c'est beau mais ça sert à rien offert à
chaque jeu sans jouer est là à chaque
parent foncé mat damas schiste d'anne
decis finito 6 ou 10 6 et 1 il ya dam
des six tours 8
c'est gagné ouais ouais celle là max
elle fait du bien
gros coup de moins bien et il aimait la
tête sous l'eau donc l'arrivée un
tournant allez faut réussir à construire
là dessus alors qu'il aurait pu passer
la plus simple qui aurait été
catastrophique il passe à plus 3 il se
revêt il se remet il se remet une
distance d car c'est important
ouais mais bon je ne vois pas son
attitude
la dre délai les dents longues édition
les jambes dures la partie d'avant c'est
pas lui qui l'a gagné 1 c'est vraiment
son sassa facilité tactique alors qu'il
est très mal il a réussi à planter fou
prend des trois mais il reste il reste
un peu inquiétant au niveau de
l'attitude
je sais pas enfin s'il joue un mec plus
fort c'est là vraiment il doit
travailler doit essayer de
voilà contre contre un dépôt j'ai envie
de te diront c'est pas parce que l'autre
un peu le même le même style peut-il t
il peut disparaître du marché du match
n'importe quand mais tu as ci avait pris
un artemiev comme ci comme ça devait
être le cas au début contre artemiev si
tu fais ça c'est fini tu prends quatre
bulles d'air c'est un peu comme ça que
maxi avait perdu à dernier match avec
calme commenté lui contre naka c'était
c'était serré et peut-être 5 4 pour na
ka ou 5 4 pour maxime je sais pas il en
a perdu quatre ou cinq d'affilée c'était
fini je vois si c'est pour mettre de la
pression sur le pion c4 et le qe2 comme
le fouet aux chocs et aux mais quand on
veut pas lutter sur cette diagonale avec
l'occurrence ici on va essayer d'aller
chatouiller cette diagonale à 6 f1 avec
deux target et quand je joue des 5
on met une pression sur ces 4 et le pion
à deux aussi sera dans les petits
papiers
il n'y a pas de mystère sarine qui perd
une partie contre le cours du jeu et il
retombe lui aussi dans ses travers prend
une minute dans cette position c'est
quand même incroyable voilà ouais ouais
c'est complètement
c'est fou donc voilà des cinq des trois
quarts il ya eu cinq classiques pour
empêcher le cahier p 8,2 bouge et on
ramène aux cavaliers pour pouvoir
prendre et pour pouvoir refaire vivre ce
qu'elle voyait v8 donc ici souvent les
blancs repartent avec leurs cavaliers
parfois en d3 parfois en f3000 à
brossard n76 présent 17 c'est un mauvais
coup manqué des trois jouer c'est bien
joué tout bessette
on revient et les blancs maintenant du
coup une bonne position quand même
peut-être qu'à et 17 c et 8 c 5 arrive à
l'avantagé développement il ya davantage
d' espace attention à ce coup et c'est
d'avancer de kemal place et se fout mal
joué ça va jouer parce que maintenant
j'ai fou à 3
très bonne position pour les noirs d'un
coup là qui avait 17 tours stage est
vite fait voilà catastrophique parce
qu'en plus ça le pion en b3 donc il ya x
3 à chaque fois sur le tour c'est un
elfe ou en d2 qui est mal placée en plus
dans la structure n'a eu un enchaînement
vraiment un mauvais coup stratégique de
sarine sage quand je comprends pas quand
même sarine y les nomme alors le destin
et chaque tout le temps quoique arrête
pas de là c'est flagrant là le mec ne
s'est pas c'est je peux pas dire que
c'est un génie c'est pas possible plus
vers les jambes chez freud il ya trop
d'erreurs stratégiques est vraiment
beaucoup trop à y en a il y en a il y en
a une pelletée vrai et c'est pas la
fatigue les trucs comme ça les erreurs
stratégiques c'est mardi un site actif
c'est la fatigue mais stratégique c'est
autre chose près les la bière mis son
fou quand même pour pourquoi le matériel
hi fi de ils servent à rien le four b2
ça va pas cette position
tu sais il ya je suis d'accord tu l'as
bien remis lors pas le féliciter
oui oui non bien sûr ben baisser ces
faits puis d'accord avec toi c'est
faible sera t il
mais tactiquement il et il est très
affûté part d'un je suis sévère jaloux
successeur mais je suis vraiment pas
impressionné c'est juste complètement
égal 1 ses traits symétriques
il se prend pour un génie oui un petit
peu ainsi intel tel marketing autour de
lui des joueurs bien là qui se travaille
avec qui font des stages avec kramnik
commun pour dire le truc c font des
stages des heures et des heures
ben pas moi ce que je me suis ce que je
me demande aussi à la question que je me
pose c'est qu'ils ont ce fameux
entraîneur ramesh tu vois est ce que
c'est un si bon entraîneur ou pas j'en
sais rien j'ai pas vraiment d'avis alors
ils sont en fait là c'est la première
fois qu'il ya des indiens qui menace
d'être vraiment très fort
son très jeune très fort c'est la
première génération première fois que ça
arrive donc on va tout de suite le voir
ouais ouais ouais parce qu'en fait c'est
toujours la même chose en fait ainsi si
demain on se met à entraîner les
meilleurs joueurs de d'un grand pays
comme la chine ou l'inde où les états
unis tu va forcément entraîner beaucoup
de joueurs qui vont être dans le top 20
c'est l'histoire que tu sois bon ou
mauvais en fait c'est inéluctable avec
bien sûr ah non il est à dire de sortir
mais je voulais dire par rapport aux à
la formation quoi sa première fois un
homme il s'est formé tout seul quoi
c'est du génie bien tu peux rien faire
rien de celle du génial c'est bizarre tu
y retournes dans cette position qui
était catastrophique sarine ouais mais
s'est fait détruire ou bekkat ah oui
mais il a joué en bi tsarine sa c3 2
joue cavalier ses 508 sarine
petite variante maison la maison mais il
a joué sans foi ça et j'ai joué ses
trois je suis prêt je comprenais pas en
plus en plus c'est je crois que ça
marche même pas mais bon après en vite
c'est compliqué je suis foutu vous y
joue pas son cas et c'est ça ne s'était
pas là il me semblait que c'était voilà
du coup ça a vraiment aucun intérêt à
placer une position catastrophique
c'est ça ressemblait ni scandinaves en
encore pire pour te dire à quel point
ces mauvais cesser les variantes ou tu
reviens cas d'amendés 8 et sur tf6 tu
fais gf
mais je crois que c'est encore pire dans
le tempo
tu vas prendre b4 qui a été quatre baies
5 la casse des quatre est bien là pour
le cavalier
allez-vous passer en mode envoi de café
ça rien on fait les échecs en joue un
coup de damas cinq si tu vas pas juste
p400 mais il va faire programme à 6
j'imagine même cavalier des quatre baiia
de là pour tout le monde d'ailleurs
peccata qu'at il fait petit rang qu il
accueille des quatre tickets proie aux
6h à 14h à 100 là encore caresser
artistique narbonne et une partie pour
la retouche le néant de l'appart sarine
ah oui je suis méchant mais voilà
excusez moi je suis obligé alors là
c'est terrifiant c'est terrifiant ce que
nous fait ce que nous fait tenir à nyala
d'ailleurs cette sieste a décidé de
damages 5 pour clouer tripler les pions
quelle horreur tu imagines tu plantes ça
bien sûr c'est logique
puis ont trippé sur la colonne f ça ça
fait longtemps que j'en ai pas vu un
assez exceptionnel si tu fais ça
non en fait il est il fait un coup à
gauche un coup à droite dijoud à 25 pour
faire de rock puis fethi rock en fait tu
vois que la lui ça y est fatigué ou le
lay se touchent les yo et ça va pas être
très fatigué on le voit plus ça y est on
le voit plus après après je crois qu'il
est il est 1h30 du matin chez lui et oui
les fatigues et pape sy sarr et bkc va
voir les plombs triplet les pions triplé
mais pourquoi il prend 1,5 max était pas
obligé pourquoi ils bougent pas juste la
dame et la sef yc attend fermement de
dames
ah ouais c'était ça aussi voilà ya cinq
ans c'est très très joyeux la sarine
faut qu'il aille se coucher un hasard et
ont semblé passer le marchand de sable
sera le siège new delhi les cieux et
après je peux aussi comprendre qu'il ya
une heure vingt à vingt-deux du matin
pour pour un gamin
bon si on se fait là quand même c'est
quand même 16 ans serait difficile c'est
qu'elles n'ont vraiment c'est quand même
difficile
merci makoun d'or 2000 on passe une très
bonne soirée aussi non mais je suis un
peu triste quand je vois des gamins
quand ça se joue à la fatigue
je préfère que ça se joue au talent quoi
ouais d'accord
j'aime pas trop voir le talent talons
oui bon là c'est bon pour le match
d'aujourd'hui on va dire que c'est pas
si important que ça mais tu vois l'autre
soir quand je les ai suivis d'un toc
race est pas une preuve qu'il est jeune
les jeunes qui tiennent jusqu'à 4 heures
du mat
justement c'est une preuve qu'il a 40
ans bien sûr non mais tu vois un quart
yakine compte duda l'autre soir qui le
truc avait duré sept heures et qui après
sept heures de jeu perd parce que tu
vois son visage qu'il va juste il
fallait plus quoi il y là il a même plus
de plus deuil quoi ça c'était un peu un
peu moche voilà aujourd'hui - parce que
parce qu'il ya quand même un écart de
niveau qui fait que maxime va remporter
le match quoi maxime a fait un peu
n'importe quoi mais il a échangé à 2
contre fc ouest
oui si on fait les f-5 c'était pas du
tout l'idée l'idée c'était de conserver
cette majorité à la dame et les
centristes et tu les laisses et advitam
et à la banque il est encore mieux mais
bon c'est vraiment dommage d'avoir
laissé autant de jeux au noir c'était
quelqu'un karekin d'audace était la
qualification je suis en pour le speech
s est en fait ils ont joué quatre
matches il a eu trois matches d'une
heure et demie avant et eux leur match
durée 2 heures 30 et après deux heures
de jeu il y avait encore à égalité ça
c'est vu que enfin petit son son visage
en une demi-heure s'est décomposé quoi
de fatigue c'est qu'il ya perdu le côté
12h15 yakine qui a perdu ses 12 da qui
s'est qualifiée 12 a quitté frais comme
un gardon maison carrée qui n'est une
vie de famille massacrée vrai c'est que
les jeunes
quand tu es jeune tu es en super forme à
une heure du matin jeudi évidemment
toute la nuit tu peux jouer alors mis
toute la nuit tu peux beats et enfin lui
les trois mini jeux vous toute la lui
aussi un et pas que et pas que un pack
le paquet est très important ce genre de
situation quand toujours du petit
hommage à vlad pour les commentaires
quand même comment faire sans un mazet
nord de madrid en forme ça dépend les
rares fois j'étais pas très en forme
après mon réveil
non mais ça hier l otage le trot passion
un sourd à 6 dans le pion c6 est trop
faible
à part à jouer messi qui accueille 5
erakat
mais bon c'est quatre c4 se fait mal la
turquie va rentrer en assises finalement
aussi s'il y aurait il fallu manger un
pur moment ou un autre et il fera la
différence
faire la c6 c5 ces beaux feux 4-1 ses
huit noms peut-être fou des huit tours à
huit d'ailleurs c'est peut-être très
méchant tu la prends même pas abandonné
il essaie de la tenir quand même mais
des cas tu es fou 17 français si ce
n'est tombé un bien joué et fou 17
maintenant je pense c4 en douceur allez
ça fait du bien il reste deux minutes
dans cette cadence maxime qui reprend le
plus 4 ouais mais coûte finalement se
joue pas à grand chose
bah si comme m ses larges
c'est là je met à rire classons temps
faibles il fait il fait 2 2 sur son
temps faibles quoi c'est très large dans
le niveau de jeu mais c'est pas si large
que ça dans le scénario qu'on va dire ça
comme ça + 4 way alors est-ce que maxime
s'est déconcentré parce qu'il était
vraiment beaucoup plus fort est ce que
c'est parce que il tient pas les 3h30
concentration maximale on le saura on le
saura en quarts de finale il y aura pas
de blague en quart ça se payera cash
ouais bien sûr
il fallait pas qu'ils perdent sale arabe
allah il n'est pas parti pour la perdre
il a terminé son développement
correctement il a réglé le problème du
fou c8 qui l'a développé en un an à 6
pour échanger les fous et il peut il
peut prendre n'importe quoi ici moi
j'aurais pris du plomb personnes et a
pris du fou pourquoi pas contre les vols
ou contre mais pour mathieu aînés peau
contre aronian normalement dépôts et
quand même pour les joutes sur internet
plus plus expérimentés ouais mais bon
bien sûr petite position légèrement
supérieur aux blancs à cause du pur b6
du coup on a peu faible sur cash blanche
si le puritain bessette ce serait
complètement égal
mais on est quand même très très proche
de l'égalité a le temps de faire car il
ya eu cet échange est un peu lent ça
doit être possible
ça va pas être l'option numéro un d'al
kaoualich 6 qui contrôle et le 8 à 1
juste pour tous les candidats étaient
annulés il sera repris au printemps 2021
cette dame b2b catherine lot intéressant
donne des quatre qui jouent des airs
alors y'a pas dan franck et prend alors
ok je vais jouer pour sa famille je vais
prendre et prendra deux amis qui peut
peut-être à une ans tu reprends du pion
qui était potentiellement ça doit aller
loria pâte en france et si adam prendre
les 5 injuste c'est quand même important
salaire d'égaliser en force non ouais
bah quoi je pensais quand même un petit
peu mieux pour les blancs il ya cette
pression sur ses six donc après il faut
qu'il fasse
je suis peut pas rentrer dans la finale
avec le toit en a 7
mais c'est ce qu'il a regardé mais en
fait elle doit être égal je pense voilà
ça à prendre prendre qu'à elle de tours
à 3 qui avait 4 ans à s'être sadr est
légal ce qui la tour en civil qui est
des matchs du couloir le cas et qu'il
est en d3 ça va tout liquidé elle sera
un bon résultat une nul ici une histoire
de tourner à plus quatre mais bon il
faut quand même être vigilant un plus
qu'attendu là que tu perds les deux
premiers les dents exact
non mais le bullet ils peuvent faire
peur ça rime parce que c'est son point
fort quand même c'est peut-être le seul
moment du match où maxime sera pas plus
fort intrinsèquement ouais pas plus fort
oui ils sont ils auraient tout même en
bullet il a plus des lots mais moi je
l'aimé trop même niveau les deux ans
bull est très calé trois c'est dire je
il va faire car il a sur le coeur au
sort via ses trois tours b 3 peut-être
tour ici pour yaya is tranquillos dans
une toute petite pression quand même
rob smith joue décontracté il est
affalée dans le truc il a raison hein
pas se mettre la pression pour rien
well bien bien vu jikou11 c'est vrai
quand il prend 30 secondes pour des
cours logique en avril se demander
comment il peut être plus fort je me
pose la même question
ouais mais il est il a un énorme élan
bull est donc c'est qu'il est fort il à
3300 quand même en bullet ouais mais
j'ai envie de voir non ce n'est en fin
de mois aussi j'ai été très surpris
parce que dans tous les matchs en fait
il a fait ça et il est vraiment forts en
bulles est donc on se pose des questions
est ok pourquoi est ce qu'ils jouent pas
plus vite
c'était le plein de coups dans l'eau les
joueurs blesse c'est instantané
non mais je suis là dix mille pour cent
d'accord avec vous les gars allez maxime
qui place ses pièces pour jacquet et 17
et pour égaliser définitivement aller
la petite nul là qui va aller se
chercher pour notre maxime nationale ah
ça fera plaisir de le re suivre en
quarts 1 donc là il ya un match chaque
jour c'est ça non c'est un peu bizarre
c'est bien espacées dans le temps
ok il ya des matches un peu tout le
temps tu vois moi je pensé par rapport à
ce passe à ce format vu quand on parlait
qu'en fait en jouant des matches lyon il
serait pas mal que ya deux trois matches
qui se jouent en même temps du coup
ouais un peu mon idée russie mais c'est
pas vraiment le le délire non plus à
l'est donc ça veut dire que l'on tourne
c'est la dernière c'était la dernière on
tourne à plus 4 on tourne jusqu'à toi
qui est si est très bien vu le bus le
coup de moins jeunes qu'il a eu un fils
en il s'en sort pas mal parce que là il
est quand même fatigué il fat il fatigue
fatigue vite c'est une formule 1 maxime
très rapide mais manque un peu
d'endurance
il va falloir faire terminer le taf je
leur envoie une petite pub histoire de
leur faire mal surtout escales ont pu
s'y prennent très très mal ils prennent
ils prennent trois minutes de pub ouais
on rigole pas ici on ne rigole pas mon
seb
la pause à 1h30 du matin qui fait mal
pour sarine c'est vrai qu'à 1h30 du
matin la pause elle fait mal en 1856
quasiment et bien ça qu'elle est quel
beau public en et nombreux tiens je
regarde toujours les autres langues au
passage puisque après quand je fais mes
rapports du coup j'ai plus tranquille et
8 213 ça souffre côté russe ça s'ouvre
côté russe ça souffre côté concurrents
français s asus a su sassus effet voir
les espagnols ou quoi parce que l
portugais 336 bat pas mal nous apprendre
davantage et aussi par le fait d'avoir
un joueur français a clairement la 139
un petit peu et les espagnols l'espagne
doit être nombreux normalement ouais
c'est chez ce couple steijns ah ouais je
lis je les vois pas là c'est étonnant
mais je les trouvais manuellement
on regarde un peu quoi moi j'aime bien
j'aime bien jeter un oeil pour voir ils
sont 330 ou s'il y tu vois les beautés
qui sont 4000 à l hypothèse le temps du
monde
vlad et appelle les beautés il y pas le
z alors plus sage ou pas du tout aux
échecs voter ces jeux vidéo très bien
les jeux vidéo très bien mais en plus et
reconfigure là ça va être de nouveau de
nouveaux l'explosion des échecs alors
ouais je vois je le vois déjà sûr
sur youtube depuis deux trois jours là
je le sens depuis way depuis vendre
depuis jeudi en fait c'est direct en
fait
voila c'est direct ouais dès que les
schtroumpfs une affaire qui se fait sur
ces chèques
dès que ça réouvrir arrête quoi donc je
regardais un peu il ya pas mal pas mal
de gens qui stream
non mais c'est pas mal mais nous allons
mais on est vraiment en vrai pour du nom
anglophone on est vraiment beaucoup
ouais c'est clair c'est fou comme gotham
celle ci sont 1700 l'eau avec un pull
rose horrible j'ai vraiment pu
l'horrible gotham chaise sais pas j'ai
jamais cliquer sur sa chaîne hi fi le
jeune fils est horrible il ya pas une
caméra de qualité monstrueuse lui aussi
s'il a une carte d'acquisition à une
caméra monstrueuse
ok je crois que j'ai trouvé que c'était
du hd son truc quasi ya un bon match sai
wan williams compte daniel reyne gc ca
annoncée du la pub
ouais tu regardes le jazz comme officiel
parce qu'il raconte ouais ils passent
sur des pubs parce qu'ils foutent rsa
s'élève plus haut que jeter un oeil
ouais c'est une pub pas ils ont fait un
match ils ont fait un match et je pense
que williams est censé être plus fort
non seibel je pense aussi
c'est comme un canard au top pour pc
actuellement bas je crois que en fait
c'est même pas je crois qu'il est une
carte d'acquisition avec une caméra en
fait c'est encore plus compliqué mais
c'est pour faire ça c'est du matériel
vraiment cher et la peau dure combien de
temps c'est vrai c'était dix minutes en
la première c'était dix minutes la
première mais ils ont un bel échiquier
la ccia score mystream avec un autre
truc qui fait des animations quand il
joue oui ça explose les jours le truc
père c'est assez marrant quand en fait
non séparé regarder un autre arrive ont
regardé ce que j'ai lu ce que faisaient
les autres je regarde souvent en fait
pendant les pauses moi aussi ça m'occupe
déjà de base
et puis moi ça me permet aussi de me
faire un avis sur la qualité des
compétitions et des formats qui sont
proposés entre guillemets ouais c'est
important donc dû qu'en fait je regarde
on attend de voir ce que font les
concurrents ce que font les way ce que
font les autres langues etc
tu nous as tu vois un peu ce que ça a
donné si les gens accrochés au poids là
tu vois parme 213 en russe
tu vois que ça accroche pas du tout quoi
peu importe je vais leur parler de mon
format de 7 à la fin de la saison je
renverrai un mail je le fais chaque
année de façon alors à cannes il renvoie
mon mail à la fin donc le format 7 est
beaucoup mieux et que et que ça créerait
plus de d'intérêt pour la compétition
j'envoie mes mails chaque année il
repartira en décembre comme tous les ans
c'est marrant en fait chaque année
répond de la même chose toute façon donc
ils vont me répondre que c'est pas bien
mais je re je le referais et les à
reynès qui compte les remettre non non
plus non plus dès qu'il ya un truc que
j'aime bien en fait ça s'est reflété se
faire avoir et ça saute ça sonne c'est
sûr ça le réunir et essayer de marquer
très rapidement la première c'est sa
seule chose qui ait un petit doute
s'il fait un gros début de session il
peut il peut il peut instaurer le doute
chez maxim ici et rangée dans l'espagne
montmagny non non il me me répondent à
mon mail
une fois j'ai même été en échange de
mails sur une dizaine de mails avec le
cio fait que le gars qui a le plus de
parts de chess comme pour parler de mon
système de 7
j'ai défendu mon système à fond quoi
j'ai tout donné mais ça n'a pas marché
on peut être bannis 25000 secondes
ouais c'est long
c'est non non mon mail mon mail mon mail
sur les sur les sur les sept îles et les
montées de des cheveux en échelon quoi
mais n'a pas été conservé
doc ça va reprendre j'imagine à quoi à
oui puisqu'ils sont en place les joueurs
non la personne
le livre à leur bac book corresponding
skweres intéressant point 1200 ou trop
élevé donc autre chose à travailler un
petit peu trop élevé tu devrais d'abord
d'abord commencé par des choses un peu
plus simple mais c'est un très bon livre
en tout cas c'est marrant juste noir pas
ledit krenz a annoncé le retour des
arénas dès le début 2000 21 juste un
petit truc drôle par rapport à ça parce
que j'ai fait un mail c'est frais c'est
le genre j'ai fait un mail il y a deux
semaines pour dire qu'il y en avait gros
que ça me faisait chic les arrêts n'a
été arrêté que c'était très bien et est
dans mon échange de mails j'ai un petit
échange mail d'où la conclusion était
que ça l'est peut-être fait mais que
pour les européens en fait est mise en
avant que pour l'europe mais c'est
exceptionnel en fait il ça a un rapport
avec mon mail faisait c'est le premier
mail qui sert à quelque chose quoi il me
fait tellement plaisir à j'envoie des
mails c'est terrible je renvoie tout le
temps d'éveil quoi je suis très content
si c'est le cas je suis très content on
verra ça il m'a refait avec sa nouvelle
tête le premier mail utile de ma vie
quoi
allez allez mon max ou ailleurs max la
première la très importante pour être
relâchés après si tu veux ouais faut
qu'il arrive à +6 là dans cette zone là
et puis on n'en parle plus donc en gros
là ils vont jouer c'est minutes y'a pas
d'un gréement c'est ça si si c'est un
plus à ses neuf parties en vous compte
huit ou neuf parties à ok ce que sinon
j'allais dire 15 partie du coût 8 ou 9 9
contre compte 109 donc 9 + 4 il perd 7,2
et c'est mort quoi tu vois ouais je veux
aller chercher trois victoires oui mais
bon il est quand même pu dit maxime ne
pas l'avoir fait de salles sur la déco 1
comme quoi ça lui servira de leçon
en fait il était tellement au dessus
et puis après il a encore gagné c'est
juste après c'est cette fatigue
le fair play je trouve ça beau c'est
bien qu'il ait fait ça qui fait le cadre
déjà il repart là dessus alors là c'est
autre chose un autre à lotir a fléchi
déjà cinq secondes pour le problème mais
c'était impressionnant
j'ai jamais vu ça quoi il très forts en
bulles est avec 10 secondes contre eux
bon allez il a enchaîné c'était
peut-être le temps de s'asseoir à
l'essai il revient mais il n'a pas un
plan b là dans son ouverture
ouais on est du real mais bon on est
déçu surtout on est déçu parce que tout
le monde le présente comme le grand
génie et ça va pas du tout mal et ce qui
va et ce qui va trouver deux dames v8
ah non il repart il repart sur cette
ligne les deux ordres
il va il va trouver dame des victoires
il va livrer à le trouver il a dû
regarder c'est pas possible au regard
des enjeux dit fédérer sur un texto
c'est pas quoi ceccarelli sac et ses 2
qui empruntent cette caravane est à même
si maxime qui fait des essais malki à
sourire il a rigolé ça l'amusé enfin
c'est pas très drôle hein tu va la
perdre
ça ne rigole pas trop mal merci à ces
normes
enfin il arrive pourquoi tu ris et le
fait jouer c'est bien le faire jouer bon
après cette position attention ce
qu'elle est quand même pas folle folle
pour les blancs youpi puni il ya un truc
intéressant il écrit que le 1 + 1 c'est
pas du 1 + 0 donc niall peut-être paru
si fort dans cette cadence et c'est vrai
qu'il a raison de le souligner un
commentaire pertinent
bon là je n'aime pas affolé sur des
blocs car ayant réussi c'est fort hein
il tient les cas d'importantes positions
noir beaucoup plus agréable au niveau
des pièces ce pion détroit cette dame
bessin pied bien placé au chaos les qui
peut s'installer en d4 entre les deux
pions mais toujours ce petit à petit
avant sautant à risque il va chercher là
nul maxime dame f5 qui a aidé cat way
we're il va sauter sur le rock un
problème là dessus c'est la position
n'est pas allé il en reste à l'e99
c'était c'était la moyenne haute on va
dire qu'il en reste 8
allez on va voir ce que ça donne
maintenant ils allaient noir et niall
qui a changé un qui a joué ses quatre
ans premier qui veut pas revoir de
gambie dame a accepté depuis un moment
très théorique encore une fois mon saad
voilà très théorie ici ans continue ce
que je vais dire fouet f5 four b2 donc
foulé cette les cavaliers mais quatre la
cavalcade qu'on échange tout comme m
donc supérieure pour les blancs parce
que on va les deux colonnes nous verse
et on peut on à ce flou g2 qui est
supérieur ou l5 un petit h 4 ça peut
être pénible arrache 4h 5h si cela cas
dans la jungle donc on est faible sur
cases noires d'un v6 et bien jouer ou
pas très bien ce qu'il donne c'est 7
du coup on a des seins et maintenant
donc mal joué c'est 2006 et par les
trois tempo après en bullet il était
tentant une dame b 6 ouais ouais ouais
mais vrai que ça très bien répondu à
corps
maxime qui a très bien joué force
tranquille sur cette cession serait bien
qui nous lie qui nous engage la
peut-être un petit os 6 des cinq
d'attention reprises à bout je pensais
qu'ils allaient faire des 5000 a
peut-être vu quelque chose mais il peut
faire des cinq mois non non ouais il
peut faire des 5es à la colonne s'est
quand même il n'est pas gêné par la
colonne des des blancs la tour qui va
rentrer ans et de l'autour ans et 8 ça
se passe plutôt bien pour pour max all
away très bien pour le moment il n'est
pas du tout mis en danger
danon b4 s'installant ses trois petits
coups durs et 5 pour éviter le drame
enfin si ça va échanger non là c'est moi
qui ai missclick 4,6 dans sa tactique on
est retourné sur la partie ça les change
petit à petit parti sans histoire un
finalement seb ou les deux joueurs
enchaînent les échanges très tranquille
pour mox ça devrait ça devrait faire
deux nuls bon début mai mais voilà
l'écart n'est pas encore n'est pas
encore fait
attention tout de même un ou un pion par
cb qu'il peut être dangereux
n2 dames pour faire attention c'est
toujours fort après macadam des 5 et
l'échec perpétuel sans faire surprise
[Musique]
est donc à combien de temps il reste 25
minutes voiturier que yayi valoir que
qu'un sixième 1 du truc qui va jouer sa
petit problème il n'y a pas d'âme des
uns donnent b3 ok c'est là elle peut
commencer à être pays parce que dans
final de dames les pions passé sont
ultra important ouais ouais là celle-là
faut que l'on revienne vite en d6 vous
pourrez dans le cadre de cette loi il
n'y a pas de gamme c6 du coup faut faire
gaffe à perdre un set
bref un ça me fait pas trop peur ça mais
le pion b5 sur ac se redresse pas
rapidement ça c'est pénible 1 puis pas
jouer ça il a bien joué la finale bien
garder l'attention pour faire ce pion
passé ouais mais là maintenant comment
tu progresses avec les blancs voilà
c'est compliqué son roi doit peut-être
aller à angers 1 il va peut-être tentés
à 6
bien joué et b6 d'abord l'échec
perpétuel à temps yat il n'y a t'il pas
seulement parce que tam à cette baisse a
rayé comme ça j'allais dire si les dames
d2 et mesdames à cet ep cet arrêt du
coup là il peut pas protéger deux
bateaux autant il peut pas mettre la
dame en bessette et faire rager deux
jours des six la très important ouais un
berger trois des six qui avaient dam des
cinq échecs mais il va réussir à refaire
nous lie les deux joueurs ont raté des
trucs là ouais bon après c'est hyper du
saint père devrait là ça semble assez
nul lanoraie mais ils ont tous les deux
ils ont tous les deux raté atténue les
dégâts tant mieux pour maxime menia la
loi c'est marrant parce qu'il a l'air
d'être plus plus propre bulle est
quasiment quoi c'est fou c'est quand
même si j'avais cavaliers à 6 ans ça
doit exister mais je connaissais pas ça
ça fait tourner le chrono comme dimelo
kitschouille après ça a été en notre
faveur mais c'était pas volontaire un
maxime qui a pas voulu se mettre dans
des camps des problèmes pareils
quel âge à sa réunion en tchador baye
niasse arrive et c'est étonnant
étonnant il va faut que maxime
continuent comme ça ils le sentent
mais là pas prendre de risques à chaque
nul chaque nuit le rapproche de la
victoire très clairement ça c'est des
positions idéales à jouer pour lui
petite finale aucun risque très peu de
risques avec une bonne structure
c'est vrai que c'est parti peuvent être
longues et du coup prendre beaucoup de
temps
on prend du temps on prend du temps et
on tue tu l'adversaire petit à petit et
à faire tourner leurs un gars du fleuve
trois fois quatre peut-être non non ce
serait débile d'échanger les fous de
cases blanches mais oui comme ça passe
et j'ai beaucoup lu ces fous qu'eux mais
ces coûts sont beaucoup plus logique à
la sarine en une minute
incroyable et jaune hyperactif y jouer
c'est choquant mais j'étais bien c'est
pas pour avoir commenté de ces matches
j'ai remarqué ça plein de fois fait si
vous assez mal tout le long
pas assez mal entre guillemets c'est
très tactique est assez bizarre et tout
d'un coup ils arrivent en bullet et le
mec c'est josé chaque c'est très
étonnant
il ya l'impressionnant goulette abaissé
sa note je suis complètement d'accord
avec toi ouais je suis et je suis désolé
d'avoir été c'est la réalité mais si
nous a proposé pour le match était
[Musique]
s'était pas digne d'un joueur du top 100
mondial
alors quand du net ils vont se ruer parc
en boulettes je veux nommer là il est en
train de marcher sur maxime n'ont été
très fort la prendre le point dans cette
partie à et l'assomption plus et ils
pressent son cou ses coûts sont rapides
ces coûts sont beaux les pièces sont
bien placés ils cherchent les faiblesses
il ya aucune erreur mais c'est pour ça
que moi j'étais si sévère sur sur sa
pendule parce que comme j'ai déjà vu
jouer comme ça voilà comprends pas
pourquoi il a pas capable d'accéler
règles plus de temps je n'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est fou
psychologique je sais pas mais là il
fait la partie parfaite très très bonne
partie basse c'est une leçon là c'est
une leçon c'est nos horizons et la
poussa à l'albanie là toute avancée la
jouer parfaitement
je crois qu'un très beau truc qui a
foulé en vendée photo dr roy prend des
airs de presse il le plan tant le reste
est monsieur sarine avec à deux danseurs
exceptionnels de venir planter sans
bulles est à ça c'était beau à le
tourner un pour dévier le roi et fait
rare on l'a notre candidat au titre
mondial quoi ça joue mieux
ah ben quand il joue comme ça ouais tu
comprends pourquoi il est talentueux
pourquoi pourquoi il ya des espoirs sur
lui
c'est là une très bonne partie vraiment
une très belle partie
ben ali leïla c'est peut-être la partie
du match d'ailleurs finalement celle là
mais ouais c'est là du coup la maxime va
devoir vraiment réagir parce qu'on va
avoir un match très serré sicard celle
là il faut surtout pas que sarine
reviennent à deux points mais ça
pourrait être très pénible mais bon
c'est surprenant et pas toujours enfin
tu joues un cadavre pendant trois heures
et puis d'un coup tu joues garry
kasparov
ouais mais c'est pour ça que c'est
important de jouer longtemps pour être
bien sûr et du coup là tu es plus sûr de
rien on s'est c'est déroutant quoi il
faudrait qu'il le match dure un peu plus
longtemps comme cession serait quand
même plus rassuré sarine qui fait une
bonne partie encore et toujours les
pièces au centre tout est bien fait mais
position équilibrée elle est là il faut
prendre quand on prend des six et voilà
ok donc la maxime est dans le rouge
pion en moins bouché atempo qu alors que
tout à l'heure ils réfléchissent et une
minute trente pour l'un des coups
complètement absurde
ah oui c'est c'est le jour et la nuit
c'est un répréhensible car f3 carige et
quatre aides à mach 4 peut-être où damas
ces cd où tu en es tu sais que ça doit
pas être facile dans la tête pour maxime
c'est incroyable c'est pas de mercredi
même si c'est quand même il s'est remis
en mode sérieux ce qu'il sait que ça va
être très chaud
bon ça va être de vrais la perdrait tout
de suite tu en prends à vii fini avec
cavaliers
j'ai cinq enfants ligne et quatre pions
de plus en finale c'est la cata et le
jour à la veille vraiment les joue très
très bien la sarine maxime qui tente le
contre jeu réagir bien jouer sa cave où
ça fait mal en fait tu as ton g7 est
tourné sept et dames c'est cette way ah
et si tu joues rouges suite y avait
tourné cet été bénéfique et d'ailleurs
pu face à maxime qui a bien tenté
est-ce qu'il va la jouer l'amazoo c'est
à dire d'un match 4 ou est ce qui va la
jouer à la dame prend 1,7 alors il a en
plein rush limbaugh
rien ne lui fait peur ils maîtrisent
complètement le sujet il va les faire
dame des cinq échanges les dames il va
tu vas voir évoluer chez babolat tous
les coups du tennis
coup droit revers et ses plus de 20
joueurs
c'est incroyable s'y attendait pas du
tout est ce que est ce que est ce que
finalement on va pas on va pas payer
très cher la baisse de régime de max un
qui aurait pu attaquer les bulles est à
+ 6 puis 7 sans aucun problème et qui se
fait une frayeur s'appuie là ça pue les
gars je vous le dis franchement moi la
laiterie cat
alors là il faut pas la rater celle la
b5 et c5 je vais te mettre un truc très
beau à l'écran la seb je vais te mettre
le match
les chances de gagner d'après le d'après
l'ordinateur qui est complètement pété
un cerf que maxime n'a pas perdu deux
critères tout fait partie mais met
l'ordinateur continue à lui donner 90%
de chance comme il ya comme ya 10
minutes
bon allez braquer laisse hélas il faut
le finir tu joue ses cartes jouber 6 et
explose tous là
6 oumar ouvrir cette colonne belle à
chaque fois il le fait pas ça m'énerve
et 6 à 5 peut-être ça va aller et si on
prend ces quatre mois il veut b6 a6a a6b
6 bon allez il est très bien à l'attack
des noirs n'a même pas commencé
clark et leur nom avec ce qui lui met
dans les ouvertures c'est quand même pas
normal de ne pas avoir fait plus l'écart
1 alors ok allez faut prendre le point
ici mon max pas faire gaffe dame prend h
quatre cavaliers feront attention vous
focalisez paru quand même elle pour la
position est très très solide
when the stars in trouvent les coûts les
ressources madame le four g4 attention
et se casser cette qui tient la maison
il tient tout on n'arrive pas à rentrer
sur casse blanche au cas où il a droit
des huit la partie qui était rêvée
fouache 3 dans l'autre à imeda machin
c'était peut-être pas si bête hein parce
qu'il va pouvoir rentrer peut-être sur
casse blanche
pas sûr allez mon maximum à qui a
peut-être des caraïbes 4 qui arrive avec
cavaliers prend à peut-être wade 8 3 au
7 du coup pour venir colmater les cases
noires voilà papa sein des vaches un
très beau comme l'aurait déjà une belle
partie vraiment marche qui se réveille
car les dessins qui des cavs a lieu
quatre peut-être des fouets f3 qui
peuvent traîner c'est ben ouais il a
pris effet hier en sûr là c'est très
très sûr c'est très bien joué ça ouais à
la dame en a un qui défend h2 qui
rejoint diagonale parfait parfait ça va
ça va partir
ça va partir en bouffe agents à 7 un
jour ou l'autre f4 f5 attention quand
même on la tension qui ont des brûlures
alalalala ya peut-être un dames 3
milliards da c'est la cata absolu d'halo
3 relâche c'est fini après 2003 ouais je
croirais ailleurs aux gagnants je crois
ouais ouais ça ça a tourné deux fois là
où laure n'est pas si tout
du moins zen olala le miracle ouais là
c'est miracle restera on va me demander
5 c'est bien il reste combien de temps
treize minutes 13 minutes il doit rester
à 4-4 partie la carrière solo vital
celle là elle était vital ouais on
repasse à + 1 puis ça c'était la cata
ils étaient 3 fessée d'affilée c'est une
machine qui s'est réveillée par contre
ce sera un match de bullet en 3h30 à mon
avis ça ferait très mal
quel match en tout cas maxime à la
superbe se faire plaisir un énorme match
sarine sarine qui est maintenant à
peut-être un peu la tête sous l'eau il
doit savoir qu'il a raté une grosse
occasion si il sait que trois points
d'écart c'est quand même beaucoup il a
plus droit à l'erreur
il attaque le droit une nulle encore
mais pas plus niall si maxime gagne la
moindre des parties ce sera ce sera
terminé
voilà une très bonne position max le
qualifiant d 4 l'avant poste
ouais c'est parti va pouvoir rentrer
dans une finale très très sereinement
notre pote permettent de refaire cette
finale qui égale les tours sont au
centre
ils contrôlent la diagonale vraiment
très bonne position pour les noirs
manial qui aura qui aura pas réussi à
régler ses problèmes avec les normes et
maxime lui qui les a bien réglé un se
fait longtemps qu'il est plus sous
pression avec les pièces noires maxime
sans jouer son répertoire principal pour
laval au niveau du bonhomme
ces échanges
si tu veux avoir une tour qui va venir
en 17 noms côté maxime
ouais il peut prendre en os 4 c'est ce
qu'il a fait une bouffe jeu est cloué à
gagner le pion 1
il va clôturer le match max ouais il
profite à la fin du tournoi
la partie d'avant c'était gros tournant
en plus avait clôturé le match avec 30
secondes d'avancé à la pendule
ouais ça va faire du bien webb à la nage
d'or fédrigo en fait l'île la sortira
pas ça c'est sûr
est ce qui les sortira en demie en
quarts contre 1 et pau je pense pas à ça
dépend de l'importance qu'ils dada ce
speech s je pense assez assez minimes
féminines
après peut-être en finale contre un
écart ou quoi oui oui en finale pour un
titre c'est sûr qu'il peut avec la
valeur qui arrivé voilà maxime qui prend
le plus 4 way l'annoncé là il est motivé
les déconcentrer quoi il a il a vraiment
remis une couche en bullet mais à moi il
pas passé loin de la correctionnelle
quand même il a senti le vent là on
alors qu'est une méthode ruiz 1 qui par
ray sarine dans le dur dans le très dur
avec plus d'ouverture avec baignoire et
bon c'est solide des 5,5 et respirant
lâche 4 h 5
ça va faire mal très logiquement pour
faire péter le rock le fourbe et 1 h 4 h
un qui ont engagé six balles au maximum
en cas en cas de nul là ce sera vraiment
terminé une bonne fois pour toutes la
est ce que tu fais plutôt h5 moi
j'habite ofaj 5e fou pranger ici souci
ouais c'est bien là c'est savoir entrer
là le sacrifice de qualité paraître
important ces deux quand même
la tension est là 5e quatre peut-être
way pour ramener du monde
là c'est très violent voilà sarine en
grande difficulté aux abois et bon
pouvait-il en être autrement
sébastien face à face au monstre qu'est
mvl wade nous a quand même montré un bel
apps aspects de son jeu quand même un
nom c'est à dire qu'il peut faire
quelque chose de bien car ça tombe très
vite c'est juste que je sais pas pendant
trois heures ils étaient absents à la
tour qui rende la fin des effets encore
un petit peu
ouais dame prend à chauray fin
simplement toi c'est un wiki détour à 7
tours c'est certain ça ma double sur la
7ème et on chante torse et 7 quand même
et à prendre ses 6,2 kg ça craque
complètement chez sarine
ben maintenant c'est ça y est c'est
enfin officiel à 4 points il y avait
encore une micro chances de retour là +5
8 minutes s'est terminée seb un match un
match qui se sera gagné au forceps au
match à gagner
après trois heures et demie de jeu
c'était hyper chaud quoi s'est jouée sur
cette partie coque
ouais parmi ces fous ceux d'hier a vu la
différence de niveau 1 5 puis 5-3 plus
sain que ça soit joué assure cette
partie parce qu'on est sûr qu'elle
devrait le sommet un an manor ben alors
il aurait fallu un peu plus de temps
encore voilà c'est vrai que l'écart est
trop fait pour ce genre c'est quand même
ridicule quoi là mais ça s'est senti
honnêtement ça s'est senti à l'écart il
s'est fait comme à peu près dans tous
les matches à l'heure de jeu là il ya un
moment s'il y en a un qui prend le
dessus et neuf fois sur dix c'est gagne
deux matches derrière en fait c'est à
passer car là en fait qui se fait si
c'est pas fait avant mais il faut être
en bonne forme physique un point tel
match parce que c'est vrai que le
moindre le moins un coup de moins bien
que tu t'en prends 3 4 dans ma tête et
c'est fini
c'est à dire il faut bien manger bien
bien se reposer être en forme
maxime qui est déjà en train de pneus
pas de penser aux trolls qui va faire
après le match yd il doit tenter un
troll sur la chaîne en anglais ainsi peu
il a une mission troll mais je sais pas